[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes sir yes sir what's going on
2022 ilp is back how my level sounding
round what's going on only on xbox i see
you oh donald taco
calling dibs on the first super chat of
2022 let's go pong so what's up akw
what's going on six slayer we back shawn
klepped out mongol oh
pragmatic eagle what's up what's going
on hustler motivate appreciate you
brother thank you brother good to see
you man no doubt yeah we back man good
rested everything's good addict talk to
the people right hold on
black conflict x my man put your fingers
up put the fists up back contact sex is
it here man salute power to the people
to the people
what's going on guys
yeah yeah yeah what's going on so yeah
big show big show you know what i'm
saying we have uh mr boomstick xl and
the legendary hcg you already know judah
144 what's up what's going on what's
going on the sly crow all right gerald
mack or hell you already know yeah we
back baby back pong what's going on man
good to see you brother good to see you
out of glove hustle say attic levels was
great too you know what i'm saying so
that's good so yeah man big show we're
gonna get them up in the room king will
be coming saul may be joining in
progress he's got a situation we've got
to handle so uh hopefully we will get
him in the middle of the show or not
maybe the early beginning you know what
i mean atomic sans what's going on you
already know but um yeah good to see
y'all in the chat early we're back at
that 1pm eastern everybody's football
team is most likely eliminated or on the
brink of a playoff sweetie smith what's
going on
different show okay okay how do you
pronounce that dave on shawn lot all
right okay
no doubt god will me
i see that beyond the box let's go let
me
be back on in a minute you gotta have
them come on what's going on anyway i
will see you guys only on xbox what's up
and uh we will be back to bring in acg
boomstick xl and the rest of the lords
talk to y'all in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social lower my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tiller uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
is
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine this cooler give
you some advice and invite your girl to
your squadron cause if you don't give
her that option you gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
happy new year and welcome back to the
iron lord podcast llc and the lords of
gaming.net episode number 239 and it's
another glorious sunday we're back at
the round table on the lord's date i'm
very excited about our special guest and
we've got psvr2 and quest 2 success
ubisoft plus and rainbow six extraction
to xbox
days gone versus ghost of sushi
and e3's future to discuss so we're
gonna get right into it i want to
introduce a lord who not only represents
the premier standard when it comes to
video game reviews and healthy debate
within the industry but as solid as they
come our uplifting fellow content
creators with his trademark humor
introducing the creating host of the acg
youtube channel and the best gaming
podcast
the lord of no bs game reviews
og duke defined and master of the carrot
crate who just loves for you to send
them all your expensive amazon wishlift
gifts during the holidays
live from an undisclosed location and
making his return into the realm of the
lords
my man lord acg aka angry centaur gaming
how are we doing sir thank you very much
for the amazing intro as always your
intro game is on point man appreciate
like you're you're the type of guy that
somebody's on this corner talking they
think they know the game and you're like
nah dude let me do an intro
wwe right there wwf
thank you glad to be here man appreciate
you brother good to have you man lots of
stuff going on it's been a minute but uh
what have you been playing so i know
you've been reviewing a ton of games but
what have you been playing
yeah you know it's weird the reviews
this time too are like don't tell
anybody until the specific date so but
people can guess you know usually what
we're reviewing um dude i've been
returning to so this is a game most
people don't like i liked it when it
came out and i'm loving it again home
front revolution it's a shooter
okay dude this game
i
they deserve they need to pay me money
because i've sold so many copies in the
last week by posting discord videos and
being like this game and it's like two
bucks right now and it's like two by
that's exactly right it's like 2.99
somebody was like dude i'm getting this
game and i've had people just being like
i can't believe i missed this um so i've
been playing a crap load of that i've
been playing a bunch of some superhero
stuff to do a longer term video which is
sort of cool for me because i never got
to review like asylum
asylum
and then um
that's
about jade empire
essence
yeah yeah dude there's a hack to get
some of the hidden martial arts that you
could never get and so i've just been
sort of playing around exploring the
world i like the old bioware stuff
obviously mass effect is great i'm
talking
yeah yeah you're doing mine
yes you're already dope you already know
um
do me a favor once i don't probably join
in progress just queue up the super
chats for me if you can because they got
they're coming in hot and heavy and we
don't want to get too bad but and of
course we have a lord who is no stranger
to the realm of the iop and is the
epitome of positive energy and an
undeniable work ethic as a content
creator when it comes to the games
industry
introducing the creator of the double
barrel gaming youtube channel and the
host of primetime gaming xvlog xbox
factor and the breakfast with boom
podcast
officer friendly himself
mr lee gaming trading school veteran
and the lord who recently started his
quest into the metaverse
live from new rock city and making his
return into the realm of the lords
my man
boob stick excel how we doing sir well i
mean obviously i can't compete with that
kind of intro you have certainly uh
upped your game so to speak but uh
listen it's great to be back what a way
to start off the year
i mean talk about 2022 starting off with
a bang and xbox just banging that drum
just leading the charge in basically
what they've done all of 2021 and it's a
pleasure to be working with obviously my
brothers and and and it's great to work
with jeremy again indeed i'm a big fan
of your work absolutely i loved your
halo infinite review i thought it was on
point oh thank you solid yes and uh it's
great to be here and i cannot wait to
get into these topics and yes i just got
hooked up with of course
uh the oculus quest two and uh thanks to
my man over here i got a couple of games
uh appreciated
attic i might need a an emoji for that
we got to figure something out for the
whole team
now i appreciate it good to see
everybody all jokes excited good to see
everybody kind of rocking out and i know
um yourself and you know acg has been on
it from day one so it's so cool to see
everybody kind of getting with it but uh
we got a big show so we're gonna
introduce those uh well we're down one
lord right now but he should be joining
us in progress a shout out to saul he's
got to take care of some business but
he'll be pulling up but of course you
know we still got the other horsemen of
gaming my calls with the como my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
heart of the young wolf my man lord
attic how we doing sir
doing pretty good man i have to shout
out the oculus grind too
you know i needed a motion plate
like some vr emojis y'all talk to me i'm
sorry i played the uh
i'm sorry i played the resident before
uh like the resident before game i do
enjoy it
but man sometimes i feel like i i'm bad
i like like my head's about to explode
because like i'm not used to the way
that they do that game because i've
never played vr to this degree
like instead of like you know you moving
over like slightly moving left and right
like you moved like like it's like 25 or
like 90 degree angles and so i'll be
going up there and like i'll be going in
the house and moving and i'm like my
mind is set okay i'm gonna move slightly
to the left but then
see what i what i learned is to adjust
from snap controls to smooth sometimes
it's a feel like each game is individual
i noticed but i've noticed they've tried
to get better with that for people who
have motion sickness so it's it's i know
it's like for each game it's like a
an individual tweak you may have to do
but maybe i don't know maybe for
resident evil you already found it but
i'm sorry continue
and you know i have to give a shout out
there's a game i played yesterday i
already forgot the name but
it it it's kind of like it kind of
reminds me like those old mmos like
runescape and like so i'm playing it
and they're like build a pouch so i'm
sitting here like i'm like i don't know
what to do like and i'm seeing like i'm
hearing the this this this woman in the
other room she's like oh that's what you
do and then like like before i know that
that chick like three people and like
two little kids are helping me build
this pouch
yes
um
i played that as well recently when i
got my quest two weeks ago and uh
i know that on their steam even people
say how positive that community is yes
and they very much are like when i
walked in people were like hey man you
need any help with anything blah blah
blah no grifting none of that join my
guild
you know what i mean
township tale township tale yeah yeah it
was giving me um yeah it's giving me
kind of like i know what it looks like
it kind of looks like favor but i agree
with addict it's more of that whole like
rusqued but very friendly like kids are
coming to me look i found these bugs in
the wilderness i can help you get them
i'm like yo what's going on
what else you doing
what's funny is like
we after we built my pouch we're
building other people's pouch i
literally was just taking like sticks
and rocks and throw them at them i
wasn't like that i was like i was like
you're gonna need this stick you're
gonna need this stick you're gonna need
this rod
that's so cool
what else you've been rocking sir
um
what is that game called i always told
you their name which one damion
that that is by far some of the most fun
i've had
in games in a long time
like it got someone like me
that i've always been like i've never
really been in the dungeons and dragons
thing that was like
maybe i should be in the dungeons
dude if you're not you should be like
yeah we do weekly games and dungeon
dragons is awesome it's it's it's good
man every old school d d guy right here
i've never played d and d brought to
that again now i get it i get the
addiction it feels so dank yes and nasty
down in the basement it feels like
stranger things first yeah it literally
got the stranger things
yeah yeah
well what's funny is people i saw people
like giving feedback that was like the
one thing that they wish is like
you could hook up like
like
connect like netflix to a tv or
something and watch why you're playing i
was i don't know about all that but i
was like i i like like the the feedback
people give like it's got a very
supportive community yeah yes yes
absolutely so that's what it is
i need to get back on destiny i really
do like no doubt i felt like i had like
years to play that because of how long
yeah
you still got this whole month but now
i'm like turning around it's like yo
that's like 40 days left
it's getting it's getting tight here i
can't believe
no no no no let's help out a little bit
before we get the kick in leslie i want
a little trouble chats because it's
getting a little crazy so um hold on we
got my man donna taco he said he called
dibs on the first of chad 20 22 salute
brother good to see you and then 108
dragon tv brooklyn stand up dragon's den
what's going door happy new year's
brother so you already know game shows
yesterday yeah good show yes yes gaming
for a table to follow out of super chat
happy new years to the best podcaster
tonight looking forward to all your
content wish i could be there and as
always
hey king hey booboo
hey kim
hey forte
[Music]
i didn't gotta help me brother it's
getting crazy yeah look look let me get
these members we got uh
tyson lewis with a three-member uh
three-month member happy new year's all
the lords wishing y'all a
2022 for all everyone is level up this
year
uh from the homie from switzerland peace
it's always crazy to me like where
everyone is i know what that is so cool
like to me i love that about we got it
smitty smith with a 23 membership that's
a long long time that that's longer than
most of my relationships
[Music]
then we you already read that then we
got the 26 months
from project ego the four horsemen mr
boomstick xl and acg wow this is going
to be an epic show then you did uh
gaming forte then we got the 18 month by
mad max
mo okay no it's it's big mad mo yeah big
big bad mo good morning realm acg boom
and the lords welcome back
sunday or complete once again salute
yeah oh my gosh then we got eight teams
yeah we missed all this is us missing
solved
yeah one p.m start the time great
uh man one yes 1pm start the great way
to start the new year's
c
i'm not trying to pronounce that oh yeah
okay okay okay
uh and bootsticks great show incoming
share
i have it on like my smaller screen
that's why i'm over time reading some of
these okay then we got solo backslash
with the 19 members wow the 19 member uh
afternoon lord salute just got a quest
too
played lone echo and beat saber okay on
my quest to content is king though
forget price they got to have games
people want i feel that respectful we'll
get into that respectful
then we got the five dollar superchat
from uh
k
st
okay asante happy new year gentlemen
all-star panel for here i'm
here for vr talk demio got me hooked
yeah looking forward to a session yes uh
then we've got a 10 hour superstar from
amy veteran what's up
oh we uh we'll listen later have a
question for carl what's up i am looking
to upgrade the tvs i have a samsung oled
2021. do i get to see one or wait for
the c2 for a year from now uh ces is
coming up maybe just hold on
what's going on for us before but this
has already passed yeah
and they showed some stuff yeah what do
you think acg
um i mean that is what i do on the side
to sell hd tvs
i would say i would say no i would say
get whatever you want the current stuff
that's coming out is going to be a while
and pretty expensive what we have now is
very good okay and um i mean dude some
of these tvs are
are nuts now yeah and we don't need 8k
content tvs you don't need anything like
that um you can save some good money
right now tcl is one good company that i
can't believe i'm saying this but
they're super cheap
yeah they're super cheap and they're
actually i mean some of them for low
cost are very good you know it is
definitely you know good it's a it's a
hell of a television if you want to pick
it up by the popcorn as you walk out the
girl and you grab your playstation 5 you
definitely get that television it's
definitely a good television yeah yeah
and don't do what a lot of people do
which is get a oh you know have an old
tv and don't check latency and stuff
other than friends who get like an old
tv or a cheap one and they're like it's
hdr and i'm off first of all
nothing but then they'll get one with a
latency of like 50 you know milliseconds
where they're like i can't play destiny
what's happening on this thing
it's the console it's like no it's not
like you're playing in the past they're
playing in the future
let's go let's go
uh we got 22 months from mad 0410 okay
good afternoon lords then we got uh
target man
happy new year's iop calling it now
ubisoft plus it's coming to game pass
ultimate and it will stay fifteen
dollars a month vr who stay in a flight
oh shout out to the dutch you already
know welcome up that up to lord gold you
already know mix up midweek mix-up
podcast salute lucious augustus member
for five months happy new year the run
will continue to grow this year thank
you brother wunder and dutch again for
10 months brother salute lords acg and
boom
gerald mack the legend member for 16
months or hell the ilp salute lord
cognito lord sovereign lord
kingstradamus happy he says lord pick
your diamonds two times happy new year
all right no doubt oh man bro
you lucky's office oh my god
from let me play with your joystick
i'll leave a bet a better super chat
with saw
what's going on remember five months one
time for acg boom in the iop podcast to
get it fine let's hit that like button
lords general mac 2 salute lord addict
just for attic i like that i like that
you already know and then finally craig
oh i almost said hooligan
craig craig coogan member for four
months
ubisoft one dollar per member and that's
28 million a month check my map king
that's 35 cut that out stop playing with
those weak numbers christmas pass
solstice is good those numbers is
fantastic
25 of the playstation 5 stock sitting
inside sometimes here we go here we go
let's do the real numbers all right we
caught up and of course everyone is
ready to talk about this jacket we have
the incredible hulk of this aka the
access gamer ooh
the prophet of xbox king i mean
king of the statue always get caught
giggity statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved welcome back to 2022 lord
cognito and lord king what's up
it's
incredible yo so far this uh 2022 is
it's been a fantastic bang pause um
so
[ __ ] calls me this morning
i never send him to text like send him
to like i send a text like
don't talk to me right now stop it
so he knows what that's called cold
force
he's like
he already died he made a mistake and
called me again yeah yeah
and i'm laughing so it was all uh good
fun we definitely had a good time but
uh uh so i was on um game on daily
yesterday salute we had a fantastic show
fonzarelli was on
asa
i found out a new word of slander oh for
a
video gamers like you know how you got
flat earthers yeah pancake gamers so
that's the new thing so that so the vr
dude is rising up like what are we doing
vr dudes call
regular gamers that don't vr pancakes
when he said it at first i was like what
else are you talking about who's eating
pancakes
but then i said oh because the world is
black
they do it in flat yeah they i know they
do it they they savage they gotta stop
stop slandering our brothers
so this is actually so much fun yeah but
i had a great time it felt really good
to
connect with people and have a
conversation about the sheer medium that
we love it just felt really good to you
know talk about all the stuff that's
going on because we see stuff that comes
around and you see
you know to it is fun
but you want to have intelligent
conversations
yeah oh this is uh oh the fur coat yes
sir what's going on sir
make another spaces
wow
and there you have it
i yo it's absolutely ridiculous but i
feel fantastic that you actually wasted
a large portion of your day oh yeah to
have nothing better right
about you
[Music]
who's a little old i'm absolutely nobody
but i'm somebody to you so for me to you
make another speech
shout out to phil dominus maximus
aurelius spencer what's going on he has
always justified my whole thought my
whole mission
game passes the best value in gaming
and i didn't have to spend a dime for
mass effect oh here we go
it's everything it's everything
everything y'all y'all be like oh man
you know i'm having so much fun i'm like
it didn't come out yet and guess what it
came out now
amazing guy hey did you know they fixed
a lot of stuff
are you trying to save are you waiting
they're improvements to the game
you better fit it oh i guess i did so
i'm playing this game called the
pedestrian right okay and
um pretty good game yeah yeah it's in
game passes very simple game it's very
simple it reminds me of pocket watch
remember uh uh i like that name of that
game i got to play a game called five i
need that what's that yeah so
that's it's absolutely so much fun and
there is this game called ulija i think
that's the name how it's pronounced okay
um ali jaw um
it reminds me if anybody had an atari
lynx
oh yeah oh yeah i was a big lynx fan
well this game
looks like it was made from
that that era okay so is that in a bad
way you mean yeah no
okay so okay
i always thought that atari links was
probably one of the best handhelds never
got his recognition talk
right and um
wait did somebody just say california
games yes sir that's my favorite dude on
the links yes so good sorry
surfing
oh i love that game we would sit there
and play that stuff for hours
when i put this game on it transported
me back to that era at that time i'm
like wow i wish i had my links to
actually play this game on it because it
is so
it felt just so mm-hmm
like it just took me back it just felt
like it matched that error it's kind of
what you're saying and and they were
unapologetic
in the style that they were doing
because it was it was so fashionable for
that time and it translated so well so
please if you get a chance go try that
out um i was playing fortnite with my
son uh he's pissed off with me why his
daddy doesn't know how to build
oh you got that dude that's building
while he's shooting yeah i'm i'm the
destiny dude i pop pop and lock right
yeah i'm running around
i'm thinking it's like pub g and then a
dude just start building the tower
and then he jumps down behind me and
shoots me the back of the head and my
son is like ah
because he's he'll tell you oh i'm gonna
crank these 90s i'm like what i'm gonna
teach you how to crank these 90s daddy
and it i i've never felt old until i
played with him
and i realized he has a whole different
language yeah i'm like who is this kid
right and what that generation brother
we oh man
he is a savant
like he'll see a group of dudes fighting
in the distance and i'm like uh all
right let's do some tactical let's take
out the ones
wrong game man this little dude a
swinging with his spiderman web shooters
mythics and just start shooting people
taking them down shoot down one dude
climbing i got them daddy that's it
i got a legend uh legendary for you come
think it was tactical in the back
get out the bushes daddy
i'm in there with my sniper rifle
[Music]
doing that um
and actually loving my game pass but
the oculus oh let's talk about it we're
going to talk about vr shout out to uh
my solstice present okay yes oh yeah
salute
which was incredibly uh ship timely and
beautiful
and um i put it i put it on my head
and
this this
wireless is the thing man
that's a huge indeed it is yeah it takes
you it it changes things it removes a
certain barrier every time i was was
going to put on my playstation vr one
the first one yeah besides that
pass-through stuff me and boom had to
deal with um
that the tethered stuff and all the
wires and it just became cumbersome and
i just left it on i remember why i
stopped using my vive okay
this thing here i'm in the living room i
pop it on my head i throw my little
hands inside i don't care where i'm at
i'll be in the foyer pop popping on my
head that's the portability aspect is
bananas absolutely beautiful stuff um
and and dimino
di bello dibio
i can't talk more about it because it
felt so much it was like we was all in
the same house yeah but we were playing
with our little army men yeah a little
uh you know our little knights in our um
i had the archer yes and
i picked archer because i'm a lord of
the rings fan of superman
she's getting your leg last one i know
and
he actually lived up to the building
yeah like he's able to see a long
distance because he is an archer um the
characteristics of certain characters i
know attic wanted it to be more of a um
rpg type of thing like the the warrior
needs to be a little bit more stronger
his power level uh compared to the
archer or assassin yeah like the thing i
said is like i just don't like how like
the the tank has the exact same amount
of health as the assassin's
differentiation between when you put
classes like that
i personally feel like it defeats the
purpose a little bit if everyone has the
same starting out stats that's just oh
okay you talk about the stack okay i got
you like a base stat like a base stat
okay yeah
shout out to cog for uh for for being
the
the the tank and when we ask him to do
tank situations
listen i'm armoring up i'm getting in
front of that door get behind me hold
the line i got it
that that's after about 30 minutes of
trying to talk him into holding
listen it'd be gold on the floor you
know you got to get the ball no but you
go to the back you got to tell the truth
he only had one bar held
every time he got over there gobbling
and pushing down and then we had to go
pick them up oh my god but we left them
for dead we killed we got the king the
key and we ran out of defense yeah
and me and attic was splitting the loot
in the bushes
shout out to attic for going to visible
as assassin and scouring the map for lou
and then leaving salute to him so so
shout out to attic for using his class
when the class is intended to be used
okay gotcha
is bringing it today
there's a little bit of a little bit of
a rub on attic today yeah yeah you bring
it up to me [ __ ] excuse me sorry
hoop heads
it's definitely something if you can get
your friends together you know four four
four friends playing that game
and going so we're going to have a whole
vr segment so i'm not going to but yeah
i mean this
yeah
nail on the head no doubt no doubt and
of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lord cognito
spreading that realism around the iop
not telling what you wanted what you
need to hear shout out to defining duke
my partner maddie plays we had a fun uh
defining duke talking about uh
slandering crocs and what's going on in
the latest
xbox news and that was good also check
out on ultimate for if you want that
exclusive uh hill sporter cast we talked
about what's going on shout out to
amazing chris raygun just talking about
the campaign and everything with that um
also big shout out to the last word
ebontis my brother ty got travis
having that uh destiny campfire talking
about 2022 days of eternity all this
crazy stuff going on right now with new
lights struggling to play the game so
they got to work on that and um yeah man
as king said demio man demio has really
taken over my life that is literally now
my current favorite game of 2022 even
though it came out last year we already
talked about i want to shout out all the
lords who play king
attic um solve where are you we need to
get you on soft but um yeah vodacon um
kaibatsu sinister everybody my boy oh my
boy anubis we rocked and of course the
legendary bill's still well we got a
chance to rock with him so much fun it's
like i'm not a d d guy i've never on i
mean i understood the appeal but i never
played it before i just never got into
it but it's literally d kind of meets
diablo then meets a little x-com
and it's bro it's just so addicting like
you said okay it's like we're all
together and we're manipulating that
board just shout out to someone who put
me onto the tilt so i don't hurt my neck
so i can tip the board up so i could
look this way for the whole night but
yeah it is absolutely amazing i i don't
like the tilt you don't like the thing
oh you like looking down i like
stretched yeah i stretch the board out
and make the characters
it's the way you can manipulate it i'm
i'm so
you can see other people doing things
yeah with their hairs but i'm all in the
face yeah my warrior you're ridiculous
you're addicted
give it a shot one thing that
i like doing is i i i like to be over
them like the the little stream
shout out to them it's good we tried it
we're working uh shout out to resolution
games they kill it we're trying to work
on getting the devs on at some point i
think they got something that's actually
coming to steam as well and april they
got a big roll mac a lot of content
check i think the game's gonna blow up
on stan yeah that once again it's gonna
have full cross play between vr and um
what you call an npc and uh console guys
uh xbox playstation you need to get on
it i'm telling y'all right now it's
gonna be something but anyway um other
than that the hand all the tenri event i
wanna i'm doing my um halo shout out to
343 for putting cosmetics in the damn
track now and challenges during the week
that i could actually take care of and
get so i've been doing that and last
last but not least i played for the
weekend king
i brought my switch up to with the
hovies for the new year's joint i never
played overcooked before
oh bro dude overcooks i like overlapping
yo it is acg is hilarious it's hilarious
that's exactly right it makes its humor
all by itself like just playing it yeah
bro it's like who who burnt the burger i
need somebody bring the tomatoes and
slices what's going on there's a little
bit of nitpicking on each other right
when somebody's not like holding their
own and you're just like dude i said
tomatoes not onions you guys you guys
going to being turned into gordon ramsay
did i say i wanted that and then it's
funny because it's like it's still that
over like yo there's dirty dishes i need
two plates come on what's going on
this game is awesome like
got a shout out overcooked my first time
playing it with the hobies absolute ball
but um yeah it's that time y'all so look
so i'm not here but we got to take care
of some quick business right quick so
let's get to it hopefully the people
involved will join in progress
oh yeah yeah it's that time of the month
lords of gaming dot net been blessed
with some of the most tremendous writing
talent and we have so first uh actually
this month of december we got oh oh here
they come here they go here it go let's
go sis let's go
little dolly lady lady lyric can you can
you hear us so your level's good can you
hear us
yeah i can hear you all right no doubt
let me uh stretch this out so the people
can see you we get this going out right
and of course yes like i said tremendous
time in a month and um look we got
outstanding writing talent so this month
this past month of december we want to
shout out to outstanding individuals
demonstrating consistency and dedication
to our lords of minute segment always on
the pulse of the culture you know and we
gotta shout out so let's start first by
putting our hands together for lord
dizzy's co-scribe of the month lady
april what's going on sis
congratulations congratulations
speech
oh well i didn't really prepare a speech
speaker
because i didn't know that lord
community even qualified me
yes it does you put in a lot of work
well yeah your lord's minutes is
different than everybody else's yeah you
deal with saul so yours is the lord's
law
own version of overcook
right just dealing with him
we have lord's half hour
yes lord's half hour that's what y'all
joined him dude what's this yeah i
appreciate i appreciate the work you've
just been killing it and the consistency
with the topics you know talk to the
people we love what you're doing out
here
yeah um i was excited to do it because
you know our
editor-in-chief who
is leaving yes unfortunately josh
freddie
he's still around no don't let him fool
he's still around
he he's he's haunting the walls
his spirit is around no no
he brought the idea up and i was like
i'll try it because i was the person
that was like i never want to be on
camera
and when i finally tried i was like this
is fun it's like a way to
get my opinion out there without like
having to agonize over words and word
count and seo and stuff
surprisingly meshed so well yes yes the
chemistry is there you've been killing
it with the topics i i remember when i
tuned in for the playstation spartacus
when you guys really had a good good
healthy discussion about that salute to
you sis and i see another one of our
co-scribes jump into the room lord ty
can you hear me are your levels good
uh yeah can you hear me yes jerry is
this one right here man uh again salute
to you you've been he's he's he's tied
to me yeah he's tied the king
every occasion he'll hit cog up but i'm
not as busy as i used to be but you know
and talking about everything that's
going in the industry whether it be the
entertainment the music side you know my
destiny brother salute he keeps it alive
you know what i'm saying
that gave you a curve i just want to let
you know we gave you a bias curve for
the scribe because you like destiny so
i'm just putting it out there i'm just
joking
anyway absolutely
i am but i'm not but at the end of the
day salute uh man long deserve first of
both of you have been keeping this
series running again we gotta salute
josh redding you know what i'm saying
former eic still around before actually
starting this segment but you two have
been the backbone and we gotta celebrate
you so both utah speech talk to the
people
all right hey how's it going i'm ty aka
prince delos or princeton nail depending
on where you're following me at and uh
yeah lord's minute it's almost been a
year anniversary for me joining the
lords of gaming
team which is uh crazy wonderful again
shout out to josh because he basically
took a chance on me i was completely
unheard of this is my first actual um
tenure of riding really in the industry
and it's been a a tremendous ride um
working with king at lord's minute has
been amazing when i was first partner
partnered up with king listening to ilp
i'm like all right how are we going to
keep this going
he's like
we actually have a nice little game plan
um and i actually look forward to it
like i really do so like every time he
hits me up i'm like yeah whatever let's
go same time same bad channel y'all
consistent i admit y'all super
consistent
yeah yeah so again lord's minute it's
it's a special little project that i'm
glad josh and the team came up with
because it gave gave me another
opportunity basically um talk about what
i'm passionate about going in the
industry and that's the number one thing
at lords of gaming that i'm very happy
about is everyone gets to write about
what they're passionate about yes um and
so it's a great and wonderful team to
write with
i love my time here i love um working
with these wonderful people like april
um like uh josh flame all those people
they're great and yeah so again check
out lloyd's man if you haven't we have
some great content yes next couple of
minutes with me and king will be
breaking down uh the bucket boba fett so
get your mandalorians up in the chat get
your mandalorians up tonight here we're
talking about every single episode of
bucket boba fett this season yeah you
know when that witch queen come out
holler boy we're going to do what we do
yo
sho show that helmet again show that
helmet together they don't know how many
times
again
awesome yes sir let's again
lady lyric
the pranks salute scribes of the month
co-scribes of december please hit up
lord solve directly and uh get that
reward give your choice you guys put in
some work it's time to shower you
with some uh celebration i get that drip
going
i suggest an all natty
king gonna put
[Laughter]
they actually wore it first and i got it
oh there you go absolutely the value
just keeps increasing
absolutely
enjoy your sunday and again
congratulations co scribes of the month
of december keep up the good work keep
up the good work
thank you have a good job you already
know salutes a little i'm gonna catch a
couple super chats and then we will
eventually start the show i apologize so
much business uh lloyd metroid shout out
to you for the four months you already
know um link on skyward sword trying to
trim zelda's bush whoa with his master
sword with the motion controls on and
missing crazy king help him salute iop i
don't know what's going on there but i'm
just going to say that's a big voice
metroid is sitting outside at
thanksgiving dinner
oh could you be slandering metroid
that's right yeah yeah yeah okay shout
out to rangie ford member for 19 months
sliding through you already know cedric
h damn i got jumped attic help me i
don't know what's going on super chat i
got cedric h with the the 19 months of
membership then we got the five dollar
from brian i want all the consoles plus
a pc with the 2080 ti
uh put the x has been putting in work on
my c1 happy new year's lords boom and
stay
and uh stay angry uh cinetar i keep
forgetting people people call you that
yeah
yeah that's an old old name i like it
though no worries no worries keep going
because i got joked i'm looking for it
now yeah it went down it jumped all over
the place on me we got 10 dollars super
traffic starchy or yeah i always butcher
that
we're gonna move on though we're gonna
go move on
to me is like 3d movies and 3d tv nice
gimmick but not going to stick around to
or be mainstream i can see ar maybe
especially when it gets small enough to
be a pair of glasses but vr
man
nothing to show that at ces yo your wish
has just come true oh the tcl
yeah they showed those glasses
that are actually
very very good um prices price range is
ridiculous but
fantastic stuff what else we got attic
and then we got a two dollar ship from
senostat oh lord
send you his dad good morning lords from
cali god bless all right and last but
not least we got the merch no doubt
shout out to my boy most infamous he got
that neck gator he started watching
early this year now he's here every
sunday should get stella on as a guest
asap talk that halo talk okay we'll look
into it we'll look into it somebody else
got in that gator clutch man got the
premium tee keep people he got the all
natty king he said keep up the good work
fellas all right we are now remember we
don't we do not
have any kind of extracurricular
activities with these net gators yes
you might be prone to violence i'm
forgetting one thing hold on before you
i apologize there is one more
celebration that i forgot to do and
again it is someone who went above and
beyond in the year of 2021 because again
we did all our scribes in a month but we
have a scribe of the year he truly was
an exceptional person you know oh man in
such a short time he's just been killing
it thought-provoking opinion pieces he's
had some great
editorials on nfts giving compulsion
games a chance you know um super star
stand out articles and it's always on
the pulse with uh news and tech so
probably present the lord dizzy log net
scribe of the year unfortunately feeling
well of 2021 but he will we will honor
him in spirit right now my man lord
flame aka joe ref goes salute for james
together for lord flame he couldn't make
it he wasn't feeling well he hit me up
last night but i had to shout him out
flame has been killing it brother if
you're in the chat put something up
salute to you he's how i first started
like reading you guys's articles oh wow
it's like i mean i didn't know you had a
website you know how
youtube you forget that somebody's got a
website so i didn't know for the longest
time and he popped up at some point i
started reading some of the stuff and i
was like oh damn i've read everybody's
now but he's definitely the first name i
saw your brother yeah he he's very beast
man just he's just been on he's been
hitting the ground running scribe of the
year hit me up brother we got to take
care of you you've been killing it and
now officially we are finished with all
the business solving bishop um anyway
let's get three minutes in yeah now
we're done now we're done all right
[Laughter]
anywho so i'm kidding this is your time
but i'm going to set you up man two big
announcements right now let's first
start off with uh playstation vr so it
looks like the playstation blog has made
an announcement as far as playstation vr
ii and they're talking about allowing
players to get a great greater presence
and allow players to escape to game
worlds like never before and they're
talking about building on the
innovations of ps5 and here are some of
the um actually with high fidelity
visuals new sensory features and
enhanced tracking along with a simple
single chord setup the key features
they're talking about from the visual
fidelity standpoint 4k hdr 110 field of
view foveated rendering headset based
controller tracking new sensory features
3d audio all this other stuff whole
bunch of a whole bunch of tech stuff
here temperature 3d eye tracking and on
psvr2 to test the motion of your eyes
and then of course they're talking about
all of these enhancements combined with
haptic feedback and adapted triggers and
last but not least they also announced
the um exclusive franchise that will be
coming to psvr ii horizon call of the
mountain from gorilla and fire sprite so
big ces announcement and then part two
was obviously what's been going on with
the quest we've been hearing about the
you know the numbers obviously facebook
did not excuse me meta did not
officially put out the um numbers yet
for uh the holidays but developers on
twitter have really been talking about
you know the success and of their
personal sales of their games their apps
i believe rec room we've seen on the
apple store the oculus app was number
one um it goes on as far as the
christmas spikes i believe um hand
physics lab they also talked about um
one of the devs a huge upward spike so
it's really been a christmas spike and a
lot of vr talk so king i'm gonna give it
to you this is your topic psvr ii and of
course the uh quest to potential great
december holiday oh well i i would like
for us to dig into the the playstation 2
vr uh as uh heavily as it was uh
promoted okay um first i i love the fact
that jim ryan uh
took the lead
right he didn't hand it off to somebody
else uh to explain it he actually took
the lead on it and that means it's real
important to uh his uh success package
all right so you know they probably have
the white board up and
on the white board uh it goes into cost
it goes into uh what they're trying to
deliver and they're trying to be best in
class with this what i saw when he was
explaining the things that were inside
the machine now
understand this is two more two years
advanced shout out to asa uh compared to
the oculus uh quest 2. and it's tethered
for a reason um the package is being
sold to you
and i probably think it would be like
400
um yeah we're getting all the tech
that's involved into it right so you're
looking at a 900 proposition in totality
right so people were up up in arms when
i said 900 oh king it would never be 900
yes it is if you don't have a
playstation 5. the barrier of entry is
the playstation 5. okay all right so
once you get uh past that barrier then
you have to figure out how they're going
to market the games uh
made with it so they showed 17 studios
and i think probably like uh seven or
eight of those studios will be working
on vr games and they showed a commitment
usually playstation never really commits
to these peripherals peripherals come
out with the playstation and they're
never supported playstation tv stuff
like that things like that never get
supported and this must be a linchpin in
jim ryan's move with the playstation to
give it something that uh the
competition actually does not address
and i'm not saying the competition as
far as oculus goes i'm talking about the
competition
inside the gaming space because the
oculus quest 2 will definitely will not
be able to outperform
that playstation uh
vr2 it can't uh it's 4k
uh hdr
it has a lot of extra tech
but where it falls short as price
that's the barrier and that wire i don't
care if it's one wire it is still
tethered to something and you still have
to be in a position i don't care how
long the court is right it can it's a
lot of things that can happen there so
uh what was your opinion when you saw it
what did you think about the stuff i was
super excited i'm definitely going to
get it to try it out i think playstation
is going to push the industry forward as
far as the fidelity of the games because
we need triple a games in that space
right and you know people were going in
on horizon i i think it was a good
looking game okay let's start with uh
talk lord acg first you know we've been
talking a lot you know behind the scenes
as far as vr and stuff like that so
what's your opinion of uh psvr too i
guess if you if you want to isolate that
to that or if you want to talk about
that as well as the um you know the
surge as far as quest stuff so i'll i'll
definitely talk about the quest stuff at
the end but i would say with psvr i
agree with king one thing that i brought
up is sony is probably the most
disappointing company for for supporting
their peripherals like we know that like
they they just don't and so psvr had one
or two good games and then the rest was
like
sometimes you're sitting there going
like dude it's it's most comfortable
headset one of the most why are we not
playing it a bunch so i'm okay with
tethered versus you guys i i will not
say that wireless isn't good i have a
wi-fi six go into the quest so it's like
perfect you know wireless looks better
than it would normally look because you
can super sample right um and i mean my
quest is decked out i'll have to show
you like i have every mod you can
believe side loaded into it but
when you look at psvr i'm excited for it
i think it's awesome that the tech is
there i think that um one big thing is
that you have developers who have a very
difficult time doing a vr version and a
pancake version of a game and one of the
big issues when you talk to anybody who
has worked at bethesda because i haven't
talked to anybody current there but
somebody who did work on skyrim vr and
they were like there's there are more
switches than people assume it's not
like vorpx where you can push a button
and you sort of hope it looks good you
want it to you want it to look great and
this headset's going to look great 4k
wired um i don't know what the bandwidth
of usb 3 is for them but the bandwidth
is not technically high enough for 4k
hdr on a usb 3
normal so i'm assuming it might be
proprietary of some kind what i want is
long yes right if it's so it's going to
be tethered it needs to be a good a good
long connector get rid of the hdr box
bullcrap that thing was terrible the
pass-through box you had to get another
one if you wanted hdr it wouldn't sync
um i'm excited for it but i do have all
every single hdr headset because i test
them and so i have the vargo i have the
hp reverb you know which are multitudes
higher resolution so i've already seen
fovea did i'm excited you know and you
can do faux video filters now on any
headset if you want to download it from
github
um i'm excited for it man what i saw
looked good i will tell you guys this i
don't i would the one place where i
slightly disagree with king is the price
i still think it'll be expensive but the
only reason is this
facebook subsidizes the quest to get it
at a lower price sony either does that
and then people don't have ps5s to play
it or they leave it at a high price
because the hand grips if you guys don't
realize if you're like adam savage was
talking about this he was like the
headset is probably cheaper than even
just slightly good
new versions of of hand controllers
because of what people want to do with
these things so the prices and and the
availability of the platform is what i'm
going to be super interested in it's not
a ding it's not a positive it's just
like how are they going to get it into
people's hands at what price
because it is 900 if you add it but how
do you add it if people can't get ps5s
right yeah um and so there's that so but
to what i saw looked awesome i was not
at all impressed with horizon only
because the trailer was like one second
the rest was some bearded guy talking
and so i was like all right now here's
what i was i was telling the guys in the
discord wouldn't have been amazing if
that was a freaking unreal five person
in vr talking instead of him okay you
know they missed they missed their
opportunity they should have had a copy
of him talking and then like you know
sideline into horizon um
what i mean by that is i didn't see
enough to be i didn't know if it's going
to be a controlled event
on rails and i don't want that and sony
hasn't always impressed me with that
kind of stuff so that's sony out of the
way i'm excited to see it because i have
every headset i think vr is awesome and
then oculus
i'm not a huge fan of the oculus i've
been pretty open about fov issues and
stuff like that because i use more
expensive ones but there's three things
that thing has man
price price and price yeah yep
and for the price
it's gnarly it's gnarly good for the
price and i'll talk about some of the
mods in the vr section but dude
no wonder it sold i talked to a dev he's
going to announce it either next week or
the week after in one day
in one day he sold more than three years
and he made enough money to basically
build an expansion for the game no plans
he was done he had patched it the game
was done they sold that many that he's
he he's like dude i can i can like take
time off make an expansion and not lose
money that's how well i sold
in in one day he woke up and he was like
what is going on
like on his little developer dashboard
he was like this is the most insane so
it dude it's everywhere it's awesome you
know and i gotta say though last but not
least they got to remove the facebook
sign in i know i've heard
behind the scenes somebody posted said i
think cognito's working on that it
doesn't matter he needs to do cognito
it's your job
listen to this let me tell you how bad
it is eight people bought quest vrs zero
have them but me they all returned them
listen yeah you know why facebook took
the day off on the weekend and they
didn't have tech support for sign in and
we wanted to play a game and everybody
was like dude if i can't and they get
burned quick that's the vr when you pay
a lot of money if you can't use it
they were like they're gone we're not
even going to try and i'm going to get
them back i think yeah because it's a
good system but v facebook's got to go
i'll let you finish it
it's just that's it it's got to go man i
don't want that sorry i just
it was it was so depressing to have
everybody excited and the entire day
ruined because no one could get on and
it was just like
yeah very very valid and again this is
one of the things that i brought up you
know initially before coming on was just
that you know as gamers we all talk
about you know our government name and
then our gaming persona right and the
reality is game hardcore gamers do not
want their government name into that or
associated with that and
the cool thing the cool thing is they
they did announce it uh last year you
know that they recognized that was a
mistake they recognized they're going to
move forward with removing it and um i i
can't speak on when but stay tuned stay
tuned this year you know don't worry
i'll be bothering you on twitter
i'm not lying man i was i was i was
trusting on twitter i was just like yeah
you
maddie
ibontis there's a couple others guys
that are like look [ __ ] i want to join
you guys shout out to jeff gordon
wendell central he's like guys games
look amazing you guys look like having
fun but i just won't do it with a
facebook account i said i respect it i
respect it and at the end of the day it
is coming but valid concern and uh trust
me when more will be revealed you guys
will be the first to know for sure but i
want to get in uh lord boom obviously
the uh psvr2 announcement your thoughts
on that and then like we talked about
the uh the the quest to kind of recent
surge or success that we hear from
developers
well look i mean everyone knows i'm a
big vr fan right huge fan uh loved
playstation vr uh originally loved it so
much when i they offered the hdr
pass-through went and sold my old one
privately and re-bought the new one with
it
uh i'm with uh acg on this that box is
ridiculous
and it's gotta go because you had to
have it i had to find a way to get it to
stick it to the furniture so it wouldn't
pull out when i moved it velcro
yeah
i tried velcro that didn't stick well i
had to get these little round discs to
kind of stick it and glue it on you know
it worked well for me boom
i sold it
yo wow
there you go i actually still have it
right behind me um i have well over 25
physical games uh there are a couple of
it's look i'll put it this way i'm day
one
i think it's gonna be i'm like with acg
this is going to be 499.99 it's not
going to be falling off it's going to be
fighting into it so yeah okay
and there's a couple of there's a you
know a couple of things why um
first and foremost one of the biggest
issues
with uh sony's playstation vr and really
acg knocked it out of park sony is
notorious
for not supporting their own stuff
we saw it with the psp we saw it with
the vita we saw it with playstation vr
when psvr launched we had batman which
was
in
freaking the best 15 minutes you'll ever
play
i'm sorry
but he's right but but
when you don the the
you put the the cowl on you
in the mirror
in the mirror and you can see your arms
you're looking at the big penny you see
you're in the we're in the freaking
batcave
even when you were on the top of the
building after the encounter with
penguin and you looked down
you it looked it would it could give you
the sense of fear you're looking over
vertigo
but here's the problem
after that original release it was far
and few between
real
triple a
bombs
so they announced horizon now everyone
that follows me knows i'm a huge fan of
a-loi she's my favorite new ip for sony
yeah i cannot wait
for uh forbidden west when i saw that
this was going to be the first game i
said holy cow they're going to continue
it this is great yeah there's a couple
of there's a couple of things on the
back end of this now the head of hco
gaming we you know
asked sony some questions that they did
not answer one is it coming out in 2022
right
now
i would love to believe holiday that
would be amazing great christmas present
for boom so i'm all in i don't think so
but they asked one particular question
that it's sony and i know what they're
gonna do because
sie loves to nickel and dime us
especially fans like me
i got 25 physical games sitting right
here are they backwards compatibility
well that's the question yeah that is
yeah i knew that that was going to pop
up
and they didn't answer
either of those questions they said stay
tuned and when i hear that i get a
little nervous so this is when jim ryan
believes in generations
oh my god well that's that is true but
i'm very excited for it uh i'm a huge vr
fan i am waiting for us to get into the
matrix one day
i'm waiting isn't that like a no-brainer
it should be one like a matrix game we
should all play
well yeah that really should be a matrix
game but i'm wait i'm waiting for the
ready player one experience
i realized
and
financially
no it's just
it it's impossible i know but still it's
it's something i'm looking forward to
but getting back to the vr yeah i'm in
day one because if it's 500 bucks then
you know that's it's 500 i'm gonna buy
it i i love i love gaming so i'm gonna
buy it as for
the oculus quest 2
acg dude i swear we could be brothers
because don't you know i got my my my my
vr headset on wednesday and i didn't use
it until yesterday because
i could not merge my two accounts i know
that's what it is
you know um the support team over at
oculus on twitter i dm them
and
they they were great uh my problem was
somehow or another facebook created two
accounts
one had all my purchases and one didn't
had nothing
and it would merge the one with nothing
so when i went into it i thought
where's all my games
it was your burner account that was
called
that was when when somebody actually
goes in on them he doesn't
i can't continue let's continue you know
but but it was it was frustrating and my
wife was sitting i'm saying i said you
know what i think what i'm going to do
is i'm going to return it i found my
receipts
i i spent i spent i spent like almost
600 over six hundred dollars because i
got the elite uh headset oh battery yeah
yeah
ever i got a briefcase for it that looks
like i'm carrying nuclear devices in the
hitman you're like hitman or chrome case
that's awesome so i have everything and
i was like all right let me just chill
they got back to me and within 24 hours
because they had to detach
my
my one account from the other one
and they did it and it worked fine
i'm playing it it is
look the the the wire thing is real
not being able to not being attached to
the playstation
is a big deal and that wire can trip
people up i've seen some bad videos
where people get really hurt oh hell
yeah you know
and i i'm enjoying it like i said i i
have the quest one i enjoyed the heck
out of it i've upgraded to the quest too
i'm having a great time
but i i that
again um acg is right the facebook stuff
we know it's coming and i think that
it's gonna it is going to really benefit
you from
having the yes because what they're
doing is they're boxing out their own
competition
because people are like yeah listen i
don't want people knowing
seeing pictures being able to find
pictures of my family yeah i have on
facebook nobody wants that and that's
that's going to get fixed but what can i
say i am having a blast with it and of
course resident evil 4 vr i only played
the opening and it is
wow
wow it's it's as a huge re fan to play
that in vr is especially you see that
chainsaw guy you know
not good not good people just don't
understand 3d like when i did resident
evil 7 on the playstation vr people were
like why are you playing it on that you
know blah blah blah i'm like no you
don't understand when that chick is at
your face at the dinner table
like their immersion in 3d i was trying
to explain to people i'm like you just
don't get it yeah it's it's a completely
different
it's like looking outside when it's
raining or going outside and that is
truly the difference one gets you wet
the other one looks wet but you can't
reach in and dude people just don't i
know that some people don't want vr to
succeed but i'm like dude you have no
clue it is waiting for facebook to fix
their stuff it's waiting for all these
companies sony's already looking at it
who knows what nintendo will do virtual
boy yeah
also i got to give a shout out real
quick to boom still having this
christmas tree up like i do you can dude
i'll probably have mine up until july
but i gotta give you a question
it's the best treat my wife ever put
together and we were like you know what
let it rock
let it rock is it a real or an
artificial one
artificial yeah so so is ours so it's
just leftover but anyway sorry to
interrupt you but yeah it's uh you look
good you can stay there
acg is on to something because if you
guys remember
the demo for re7 called the kitchen yes
it was good it was so good that there's
a specific part when someone rolls a
head out i lifted my feet up
bro when you're playing that game and
you kool-aid man's through the wall
you're just sitting there and he's like
kool-aid oh yeah and i was in 3d going
like what is
happening and i already had 3d but
that's a triple a game yeah do not
realize difference i'm going to bring up
some awesome games i've been playing the
sword you guys but a lot of them are a
little patchy and when you get that aaa
game yeah dude you just don't get it
things are timed right every camera
angle is right
resident evil 7 is ace in vr
yeah you guys are killed i would get uh
i had to stop playing it in vr saints
and sinners faces walking dead yeah
that's fine
i just read it out loud when i saw it in
chat yeah
this is a full real 3d
vr game that people should play if you
don't have that man yeah we rock it
we're rocking i got to get uh king and
attic on everyone shout out to um my boy
jimmy champagne he's been rocking dust
has been rocking a couple people i know
been rocking it and they are ra it's
kind of boom it's like it's left for
dead in vr so to speak almost in a way
what's the name of it
i'm sorry to sinners and then i'm
getting confused with the other one i'm
sorry after the fall is what i'm talking
about
all right so we were all trying to get
into our game
and people were doing different things
so i was browsing the store yeah
my biggest problem with the
the oculus is i'm game pass spoiled
right yeah that is true seeing something
that's all right so i'm going through
and i'm looking at games
i'm
i'm so spoiled
a game video could look good
i don't trust you
yeah no
why should it's the game fast effect
the game pass effect it it definitely
sours you on any way you don't do things
and you look at things differently like
you look at it through the prism of
netflix so like when netflix you know
when they drop a series all the way
through
people that have disney plus
and they do an episode they're looking
at it like what the hell are you doing
that's disgusting like i gotta wait till
next week why can't you drop all 13. oh
dude i gotta sit here and move at your
pace so
again when i'm inside the store and i'm
looking at the prices i'm talking [ __ ]
i'm like nine dollars
twenty four dollars
forty nine dollars forty nine yeah yeah
that that that 49 stuff definitely was a
cam school for me so i was like yeah no
i'm like
i can't i can't partake
now remember guys i'm sure you guys all
know this but you can play most of your
steam games that are vr yes yes oculus
and they're some are cheaper and then of
course with uh wmr you can use revive
yep shout out shout out to the air i got
a shout out to attic because he forced
me to get steam
and he forced me to get among us
which is also coming to vr listen listen
the same day it came out on xbox
good job addict good job manny speaking
shout out to me to get my money back
i saw that i remember that day
good transition at it because we got to
get a bib yeah we need just uh
a partake a buffet menu or something
every game needs to have a certain
little form of demo or something to do
to see if you like it because if you buy
something and it's not good you spend
that 49 dollars you're going to be that
guy in the comment section with the
angry face or motion sickness some games
will give it to you somewhere yes
demos demos need to be
for everything fair enough lord addict
our resident vr hater and the litmus
test that i use to see if a game is
popping in vr my dms were on fire from
there he's like dude i'm changed
something
he sounded like a southern like you know
baptist he's just like oh you found the
lord
[Laughter]
they're checking my badge before i
walked in yeah right
let's go attic talk to me there's vr uh
psvr too and um quest success which feel
it on both sides i think when it comes
to psvr i'm more a little bit like
with acg in terms of the wire
i'm okay with the wire as long as i see
purpose and i'm getting something out of
it you know if you do the wireless
you're losing performance if you do the
wire you're gaining performance and like
to me i don't got like the extra
batteries and stuff
this thing might as well have a wire
hooked up to it it's called the charging
port so you know
i played that game for like 45 minutes
and it was like your your oculus is
going dead so
like at the end of the day like i get it
it's wireless but is it really
wireless it's like you you charge it
like when we play uh that divio game
like i literally can play that for i can
play that a little long just a little
bit but
you know for a good hour hour and a half
it was like five hours out of stuff no
but no what i'm saying for about an hour
and a half to two hours of it i'm hooked
up charging the the wireless head the
the oculus so yeah like to me it's like
sure
it's cool that
it's wireless but at the same time it's
just like i'm not spending a good amount
of time hooked up to a wired port so
that's not gonna really bother me to be
over on the vr
um i think that
the biggest thing that's slowing vr down
in my personal opinion let's go is
i don't see that i need
i i see
certain games it's worth playing the vr
but i don't see that one game yeah that
everyone's like yo you got to get it
right systems
alex
well it sold some but it was only on i
mean it's only on steam ps fee
would be a big deal yeah you need
multiple system sellers that appeal to
multiple different genres that have put
on multiple different types of gamers
and until you start hitting those off
like the next thing i had is like the
cost of games i look at that store after
playing certain games
that i see for the price point and then
i'm looking at other games and i'm like
should i spend 30 to 40 dollars on this
or should i go buy a game on steam i
know it's going to deliver yeah
oh it's
i i don't think that shovelware is the
correct term
but i do think they're in that middle
ground between shovelware and games that
you would want to play like because it's
like it's like because obviously you
have like the little head it's like
you're just like going through
the store okay that's nothing i play
that's nothing i play oh that looks cool
forty dollars and i hope that's nothing
i'd play with yeah so it's it's a cool
experience and i honestly say like i'm
gonna have a more in detail review
on the oculus tuesday
is so you know definitely check that on
the channel that you're watching this on
uh i see a lot of potential more
potential than i saw two weeks ago uh
you know
what's funny is two weeks ago like cogs
like because like oh you know you're
getting that oculus and i was like oh
okay
because like my mind sits like
damn no i can't get out of it
[Laughter]
the salute
it's been a fun experience and the
biggest thing i want to point out is
like
i don't think horizon zero dawn or like
making some side piece for a game
is the answer
yeah you're bigger because like two okay
to me it's like you're going to have to
make experiences that make you want to
play a vr not something oh you're a fan
of horizon we got a game for you so let
me let's do this because i've noticed i
i do want to touch this it's an
interesting topic meaning you've had off
air and um
so you're feeling because basically what
we've seen is like when we see a
resident evil 4 ported over or
somebody's big they are getting
tremendous success but you had an
interesting take addict and you were
kind of like even though that's doing
well
you prefer
new experiences kind of built from the
ground up as opposed to existing uh
franchises with a vr take on it
clarify that it's not that
i think that they're they need both they
need something that is going to attract
the crowds you know resonate before you
see that he's like yo let's play this i
love resident evil 4. so it's going to
attract people to get an oculus to play
resident before it was like one of the
first games i brought up remember right
cognito but at the same time when i
played it not playing vr you're not
really mentally
ready for what you're actually going to
play like sure it's a it's a great
experience and it works 88 of that time
but i played that for like an hour and a
half
you know my eyes were feeling watery my
head was starting to hurt because like
it's like you're going to demonstrate
this
this vr experience on resident evil 4
but the people that played resident evil
4 unless they're actually
a huge advocate for something like vr
they're going to put that on and then
they're going to realize okay this is
resident evil 4 but it's not at the same
time because like it's the game it feels
good like there's a lot of incidents on
it like i noticed i don't know uh uh acg
if you notice but like when i was
playing resident evil 4 like you go up a
ladder it disappears it gets at the top
i notice the enemies don't go up ladders
anymore like i i was just sitting there
so i'm sitting there like looking down
they're throwing they're throwing
dynamite up and it's just going down
and i'm just looking down the stair i'm
looking because it used to be they would
climb it to get you but i'm just sitting
here like they're not even trying to
climb it anymore i'm just sitting here
looking like oh okay
got like what five more minutes before
they ring the bell like and that that's
just that's nothing big to like really
hurt the experience of the game but i do
notice that like there are certain
things that's in the actual game that
doesn't seem like it fits over to the vr
thing so they have to do like a
workaround to work around it
and it's like
in in its initial plans for the game
like that's some uh something tacked on
and that they brought to the vr space
yeah just to have the resident evil game
that's what i said like
this it needs it to get those people
over there
because people will buy an oculus to
play resident evil 4 they definitely
will but at the same time
you need something like evo4
yeah you need more games like demio more
games like
you need more games like that that is
really going to captivate playing with
friends really going to capture playing
you know these games and you know
i would say the resume before is
whatever other vr experience they get
that's a gateway
right but once you get in
they're going to look at that gateway
and look oh this is cool then they're
gonna turn around and leave so it's just
like you need something else
is this breaking into the full vr
discussion right now um yeah we we're
there
because i want to ask something to so
attic thank you for pointing that out
i'm gonna check that out on resident
evil but i will say that talking to a
couple debs the first thing they stated
was when you take a pancake version you
move it to vr you have to be prepared
for a person to shoot around a corner
like this which is impossible so i was
playing contractors which is probably my
favorite vr game of all time and i was
shooting enemies by reaching the gun
around
you can't do that right in a normal game
and i was like oh my god this is it's so
far beyond and when i was talking to
devs for a shooter that they're
releasing they were like dude do you
know how hard it is
to get an ai to understand how to fight
a human right when they can't do that
and then you don't want them looking
jangly you know where their model screws
up and what he's talking about with
resident evil most likely yeah most
likely they had to cut some stuff to
make everything because they have to
make sure you're bigger in the space
collision detection all that i have an
issue also hitman's coming out i'm sure
you guys know on the pc and i can't wait
but have you ever tried to garat
somebody in a vr game because i have and
it's miserable
it doesn't ever work right it does
physical stuff in fact
wiggle you'll hear people talking about
the skyrim where they just wiggle to
kill somebody yeah there's there's
there's definite issues i think i think
attic nailed it on the head that i would
also like to see somebody take advantage
of vr
and but take advantage of vr without it
being horizon
okay even if it's awesome isn't that
really the interfaces that they're using
um
because i saw at the ces i saw different
interfaces that were allowing like the
haptic gloves they had these gloves yes
yeah i've got them grab bottles awesome
and stuff like that it actually gives
you a feedback back bro i got the vest
that shoots
the shots and stuff like that but they
also said the playstation 2 this is what
i'm super excited about the playstation
2 has heptic feedback in the helmet yeah
so if somebody knocks you on the side of
your head
you you'll feel like
attack i don't know if you guys have
played a lot of [ __ ] else it's going to
give me motion sickness
a lot of i'm going to be playing these
boxing games hit by mike tyson and get
knocked the hell out i ain't doing it
is awesome
i was just gonna say i believe the
oculus doesn't have to call it feedback
but it's certainly when the speakers are
cranked and you're doing contractors and
somebody shoots it actually puffs wind
you feel it right yeah and that first
time he did it i thought it blew the
speed i was like oh no and then i
realized it's where they are because
they do that weird thing where they're
not over here they're in a really unique
position
yeah they do that aim auto oh by the way
if you guys want it louder have you ever
put your hands over your ears and it
becomes louder try it out next time
if you put on the oculus go like this
and see where the audio go and then go
like this and suddenly it's like 10
times clearer and louder because you're
trapping it into the bones outside your
face
it's awesome the the the audio of it
right and then i went into the settings
and i raised the sound up so i was able
to hear it but
when you do that there's more wind that
comes out and i thought i was bugging
out in the house because i'm by myself
so my wife is upstairs i'm downstairs
and i'm tapping my head pass through yo
john look around look at exactly what i
did yeah that is exactly right
i honestly feel like one of the biggest
things that's going to get vr up is a
lot like you got to focus on everything
but i think entertainment is what's
really going on they're doing well
they're doing well with that because
yeah like we was in a movie theater
watching stuff
yeah some of those people was watching
stuff they shouldn't have been watching
but you know like it's an interesting
thing that you could just pop in and
watch
like 23 people i like the social aspect
yes yeah yeah that's where we went to a
mma fight right we would so okay so we
go into the vineyard horizon venues
what are the horizon venues that's what
i was going to talk about just now yeah
verizon venues so we go in and they have
a lot of different uh spaces to go in so
they have like wrestling here yeah they
have uh
nba yeah basketball game
and a concert
i waited online to get into a young thug
concert and i'm in a young concert and
then there's people yes talking in this
proximity chat
that you could just walk up to these
people and be like oh what's up what's
going on man
but what i don't like is that facebook
aspect of it
they click on you oh
and they look at you
so so here's the thing most embarrassing
moment so far in vr for me hasn't been
people around me it's been i went into
that i was just gonna mention i go in
there to watch a basketball game
and they have the vr and this was one of
the older ones so they obviously put a
camera at the game and i'm sitting there
standing courtside i look over and a hot
chick staring at me and for just a
second i was like how you doing
just for a second
it was so embarrassing but i was like
she's staring at me what the hell i got
my god it's the camera
i got something so embarrassing i was
just like
i got something worse okay maybe not is
worse
okay so you know like the mini game that
they introduced the vr when it comes to
the awkwardness your first thought like
you know the gun one yes yeah so i'm
shooting these guns things
and they give me a dual gun yes so like
i'm sitting here like let me put the gun
down so i can actually get access to
this now what happens is
i try to i know i physically try to like
put my hand on the table in the vr yeah
because like my mind from that yeah my
mind like like
it really is like you'll get so emerged
in this vr that you'll think the stuff
of vr is real real
you'll try to you'll try to like like
like get a good position with the gun
and like put your arm on the table and
then you just fall
down
and drop a gun because you're shot like
i've been shot in contractors but like
what and drop the controller and you're
like oh god damn yeah
draw an accurate guardian boundary in
your room yeah that's number one
that's number one boundary pass-through
at kickassey when you you will see the
visual representation of a grid that
means you are next to your tv you are
next to your your desk thing cognito is
awesome in that i've never seen that but
that's cool the test thing is cool
because i was able to look and go i know
where my keyboard is now
if you talk to vr people that's like the
number one but a lot of things people
don't realize when as new vr owners is
using what king is talking about which
is to pass through enable the past
you'll see because you double tap the
headset and then it turns into a black
and white version of real life what's in
your house in your room and then you
double tap and go back into the game so
you have that as well i'm gonna jump
because it's a fun discussion but look
to the uh psvr2 seems very impressive
you know i'm with both of you guys most
of you guys as far as the um the
fidelity you know i always like to see
improvements in the space 4k hdr i
always butchered it is it foveated
rendering is all right always what is it
acg i forget the connection
yeah
it uses lower resolution yeah that
excites me because for devs they're
going to actually be able to manage
hardware resources a little bit better
and be able to basically what your eyes
focus on from a visual clarity
perspective kind of is improved and uses
less resources it almost reminds me of
that tech xbox has i forgot what it's
called again where whatever you're
focused on initially and the resources
in the background with the line of
vision nah it's another one i'm blanking
right now yeah that's the thing that i
was talking to um um this guy about uh
jason ronald yeah jason knows what it is
yeah you don't see yeah this is even
uh uh
more um how can i say because we look to
a pinprick right you know shout out to
asa uh he explains a lot of these yeah
aces bc we probably should have had him
as a vr is beastie yes right so we see
things do a pin prick right really right
and and in our site
they're using that same thought
when they're when they're making the
games and stuff like that
where they're not focusing on the stuff
that we're not focusing on that's why
the eye tracking thing is so huge yes
when it comes to this yes because when
you look at something you're looking at
something and you narrow in and like i
see my mic has a little thing on the tip
of it right but when i'm not directly
looking at it it's just fuzzed out right
yeah and i'm looking at something else
and that becomes the focus so
to use those resources on those specific
things it takes it takes away
the the the the need for certain
horsepower to render the whole world do
not get too technical oh
no i was just going to say so foveated
is something that i'm studying pretty
heavily for a game i'm like helping
develop and we're starting to look at
some different stuff and fo one of the
issues with fovea did mix with eye
rendering is that you have to decide
when in the buffer for the frame you're
going to drop it in so that it knows
don't don't use high resolution right so
quest i just want to make sure because
somebody's going to mention it quest has
crest has it but it's just a little it's
automatically automatic yeah and uh and
by the way if you don't get a chance you
should be checking that out so if you
have a lower end you should check it out
you can also use side load to adjust its
levels but um there is a game eden
something seed of eden or something like
that but there was a vr game that
actually allowed for you to use a toby
eye tracker and it would it would fove
it it would basically uprez and there is
an issue with delivering it quickly
because you have to figure all this out
um i personally believe that the eye
tracking is the big thing not because
so most humans don't do this
they look they look yes so hopefully
these guys don't make it aggressive they
make it like an add-on i think the
tracking obviously
these guys know what they're doing
sony's probably one of the first
companies that will
some of the bigger headsets have it i
have the vargo which is 2 000 bucks
though yeah like it's not even in this
and it has it but it's like come on yeah
exactly
if you mix those two i don't think
people realize you'll be able to you can
scale down it's almost like another
platform if you can scale down the video
card you need because by the way guess
what's hard to buy a 38 30 80. yes so if
you can scale that down that's awesome
now i don't know if you guys know this
you can inject fsr into any game on vr
now you can inject
all the which is the
amd sharpening and so you can get lower
resources there dude it's that's the
best part about the playstation system
is that they're sort of mixing yeah
they're like we're gonna get and it may
not be perfect but man it's a platform
this is why i'm excited because at the
end of the day you know
it's pushing the culture forward so to
speak right you know and these and this
is why you know a lot of people maker
yeah a lot of people like yo you know
hit me up cog you know you know you're
technically oculus now whatever and i'm
like no this is good because i said
honestly
that's how meta looks at it they don't
look at themselves as the sole person to
drive it forward at the end of the day
they're willing to work in as long as it
gets to that overall goal of what
they're trying to say with more more
basic in a larger install base and let's
be real you know we have to give sony
their flowers in terms of kind of what
attic is saying in terms of that first
party monster ip
name right those those big game and
those type times get other people to get
into the ecosystem kind of thing so i
thought it was pretty cool i liked what
i saw as far as you know the the meta
stuff you know it's been pretty
impressive to see people kind of raving
about it and see their success i love to
see the developers kind of really shine
like kind of the stories that acg are
talking about where you're hearing this
these tremendous uh growth spurs but i
do want to finish this topic with one
last question around the thing as far as
the the three heavy hitters for psvr two
which is one what do we think this price
is going to be
when do we think this release date is
gonna be and two i believe um mr boom's
question about backward compatibility so
let's start off with you acg just we
throw it out we're just throwing you
know throwing things in the air
let's go quick i i don't i worry about
backwards because we haven't seen sony
support it even normally okay and you
have x64 hardware versus their older
hardware so maybe there's some
difficulties plus the move controllers
didn't have near the fidelity by the way
move controllers less than nine dollars
a piece that's why your psvr was cheap
that's another reason why i'm worried
about the price
um so i would say price wise i do
believe it'll be more expensive um and
i'm hoping god it'd be great to just be
wrong let sony take the loss right and
then what was the other question there
was a price release date
does it come out 2022 2023 when you're
thinking uh i want 2022 because i want
it i'll be day one of course i mean of
course like even if it's bad i'll be
dating you alright but
i i don't know if there's an i mean i
don't know if companies are even ready
after covid and all this stuff they're
prepared for vr also we should all
remember prior to quest two starting to
get really popular i don't know if you
guys saw less than eight months ago vr
companies were shutting down so let's
say this explodes on christmas that's
two years for development so stoney may
be looking at that but i'll just say i
want 2022. okay no doubt very much uh
boom let's get the three questions psvr2
price release date and backward
compatibility with your answers on all
three which you think
price five hundred dollars
uh yeah the the tech in this in this
machine is is just really good okay uh
and i can't see them coming in under
500. i i think look the reality is is
that
the playstation vr
first one only sold
five and a half million as opposed to
the 115 million consoles it's niche
only die hards are going to spend that
kind of money and actually want to
invest in dr's people are just a lot of
people are just happy
playing
on their flat screens and getting a ps5
or or just yeah or even getting a
playstation 5 which is still relatively
difficult to do it's still hard to find
these things
um i'm like i like what acg is going i
want 2022 but in my heart i just
i don't know if they can if they could
physically get the parts to get it out
there because they still have to get
people they again you said it in the
opening cog the price of admission is
500
for playstation 5. it's not like the
oculus where you take that and anywhere
you go
you there's your there's your room
sprays you know spray paint your little
circle your thing and you've got to get
it
you can't do that with the playstation
vr 2.0
they're going to need a way
and and listen let's call spade a spade
covet is still a monster problem always
and it's get and and it's not slowing
down unfortunately
yeah so
i think price 500 20 23 uh you know
first quarter because sony's notorious
for that and what was the third question
yeah backpack with psvr one oh my god if
it's not i'm going to be mad i'm going
to be honest with you prepare to be mad
yeah yeah you know listen you're going
to get a real angry boom because i have
to be mad we'll have a podcast yeah
that's the name of the podcast
you don't you don't you don't call it we
just you know change she shows up
you don't call prepare to be mad you say
prepare yourself oh my god
prepare yourself podcast ridiculous
i have a lot of games and i look i'm not
a tech guy i i just know that i plug
something in it works okay but here's
the thing there's zero reason why these
games can't work on a more powerful
system it doesn't seem like it's it
would be a technical issue maybe
but but yeah in fairness but you know
what it's it's be forthcoming
and don't blindside me with this yeah
fair enough fair fair no but he didn't
he told you he believed in generations
wow
well and he didn't answer the question
right he actually said no comment yeah
he said no comment yeah yeah the head of
exeos actually asked them when it's
releasing if we're getting it this year
and will backwards compatibility be
something that's added or launched with
the console and they said simply stay
tuned for more info that's not
confidence for me
that's like well we're just kind of
winging it at this point but that that's
what i think those are my thoughts attic
psvr2 price release date and backward
compatibility with psvr1 go for it there
is absolutely zero possibilities
backwards compatible
i feel like the price is going to be
four
over there my ears are burning
i think because i think because of the
quest they're going to take the hit a
little bit when it comes to to that
price
because what about this thing somebody
said hey with the premium
device i mean remember
you could be printing the device on that
shelf you can do that
it's just like because at the end of the
day like look like as much as i'm you
know it's going to be stronger at the
end of the day i've said it over and
over again people are having a good time
on the quest they don't need playstation
so you look at it like like a nintendo
switch situation almost from like the
point of entry ease of use portability
like kinda i don't think that's like a
hundred percent fair comparison but i do
think from a hardware standpoint
obviously nintendo has the ips obviously
but
yeah i i think they'll take that hit on
that i do think that in terms of they're
looking at it from
when we came in there was competition
but
we can't ignore the fact that
six months ago whenever they decide
because i don't even think the price
they probably got general ideals but i
don't think they probably have an idea
of what the price is going to be
yeah so that they're probably going to
look like you know we can't avoid that
oculus outsold everything on black
friday so it's just like and part of
that reason is it is a compulsion buy
sure they can't go that low right but
they can't be two three hundred dollars
higher than that either got you so i
feel like they're going to compete with
oculus in terms of pricing
i think they might take a slight loss
until they're able to manufacture it
better or you know they might come with
a higher price but they're going to come
out with games
because they did say that they had 20
games that they were developing how do
we know like half of those are vr
that's a good point i can tell you why
okay come on man
come on addict come on bro now i gotta
do i i don't have a light to do fraud
no seriously attic if
that company is selling gangbusters
pancake versions why sell to an even
smaller segment when they can't even get
people to get ps5 they can't get ps5s in
like why would they artificially do that
or are you saying have two versions like
no i
i'm saying that
they're either going to come in at a
lower cost point with fewer games
because they'll have to compete with
oculus one or the other or they'll come
in with a higher cost point with more
gains
because at the end of the day people
will spend more money
for a console they well you know at this
point it's it's it's not a console but
you get what i'm saying like an
ecosystem that they know they're going
to be able to play a good amount and
they have to have the sony has the
eyepiece not to cut you sorry
uh and
i think it's
early 2023 i mean yeah 20 23 yeah so
nobody cause i i don't think they're
going to make it this year okay so you
the cog would you mind if i read a super
chat please because it really does make
a lot of sense
um
drops a fight out super chat thank you
so much for supporting the lords
as a as a reminder uh
i just lost it yeah it jumps
flying in brother i know
it says here as a reminder psvr came out
at 399 without the camera and
controllers 4.99 bundled right with ik
he's 100 right that was a 500 a
proposition right he says i can't
imagine playstation vr2
uh will be less than 4.99 likely even
higher so basically we're saying because
of what happened last time the same
price they value at the same price as
the console itself
yeah interesting just i feel like it it
would depend on how they distribute it
maybe they'll give you the bare bones
and you can like kind of like what king
says like you can buy accessories to
upgrade it but you get that
no no you was talking about like the ps5
you need the ps5 and well you talk about
like you need to bundle stuff yeah yeah
yeah
all right that would be a horrible
mistake but you know at the end of the
day as long as they come with the game
as long as
i feel like there is differences between
the psvr now and the and what we have
currently with the psvr2
because they use the move controller so
clearly i don't know if it was rush but
i don't think it was fully you know
controllers were never made for the vr
that was that's what i'm saying like i
feel like because of the move controller
i don't think the vr was rushed but i do
think that they were doing whatever they
could
to get it out faster so it's like
definitely but now i feel like yeah but
now i feel like
they're they're designing a vr for an
established market now because it is vr
is starting to establish so there's more
into the research than just coming out
there oh let's put those move
controllers there yeah right there right
there like get down on the line
all right
cake price you've noticed that you guys
missed a huge thing right
and
time
okay time with time
[Music]
products uh lose uh value price goes
down uh components become more available
uh stuff is cheaper so okay let's say
the the playstation 5 is always
at 500 right let's say it becomes
in a year or two from now
cheaper than a manufacturer but they
don't drop the price point and keep it
at five hundred dollars let's keep the
twelve hundred dollar price point on the
board right let's i'm gonna put twelve
hundred dollars on the board and i know
people in the chat is gonna say stop
doing that twelve hundred dollar
thinking that's not what we're talking
about well you don't gotta playstation
five so let's take five hundred dollars
out of your twelve right now you got
seven right now let's take four out of
there all right because they're gonna
sell the playstation vr2 at a loss this
is going to be the loss the 399 bare
bones going to be a loss it's not coming
with the 3d audio headset yeah that's
coming with the 3d order
no
you you can it
utilizes it okay
remember the verbiage it utilizes it so
when you get the headset on because they
sell a 3d audio headset with the
whirlwind twist
that stuff will be there right now don't
but that's nothing cooler than this
course that's not there let's say it
digitally s5 tempest 3d audio tech make
the sounds of the fact beautiful
beautiful if you do you want the real
one like this is why i need a great
fraud alert
for the hardware in the ps5 and the vr
the other is the headset he's talking
about having the actual one maybe will
not have a headset at all right it's
like
specifically for that or something which
is possible i don't know okay check it
out so you got 900 that's removed from
there right
dudes are not thinking about the
spartacus uh proposition
to this
right so now
you're putting let's say
it's
a hundred and fifty dollars for the year
for spartacus right
all right so you get 150 on top of this
you have that now you passed a thousand
uh 500 i mean a thousand a thousand uh
fifty right
now you need fifty dollars for a game
one
one of the vr games let's say the vr
seventy dollars
oh my god
you can't be quick with that boom went
into the 70 bag all right so
you're at the the you know the the 12
20
range for the whole package i think
that's a good proposition for what
they're asking for and what they're
delivering okay right so you're going to
make up the difference in the cost of
the playstation 5
being
made cheaper with the components inside
right but you're still selling it at the
500 price point okay you're not dropping
the price point on it because it's still
a hard to get item right i don't care
from a year from now or a year and a
half from now it's still going to be a
hard to get item okay so yeah people
will be willing to pay the 500
even if they're making let's say 70 off
for each one okay that's where they're
making the money up from from selling
this at a loss i don't think and i know
the tech and stuff is there but remember
they were giving you a camera it was
giving you some move sticks they would
put a game in there and they wouldn't be
able to head
yeah
i got two
thank you for raising your hand sir i
like that i was dope continue like i
like zoom really raises fire oh you can
do that yeah yeah yeah
okay yo don't forget me y'all that's
where to get a bar off continue so you
you know they were giving you this stuff
and
the price at the time they wanted to see
it was different regimes
jim understands where he wants to take
this and i saw him taking it very
serious by where he was there front and
center he didn't let anybody else talk
about it he didn't let mark cerny talk
about it he didn't let anybody else uh
present it to the people
i don't think it's this year okay i
think it's i think it's um
end
of 2023 oh at the end wow yeah i think
wow i think for the holiday season okay
to have enough time for the games enough
time for the playstation hardwares to be
there enough time to get more consoles
out okay there's no need to rush it at
all who are you you're rushing for
you're not right
not to announce this early at cacs
right but also
you want to make sure that spartacus is
in play
okay because that's where you can have
your sampling
the problem that i have with oculus
that's where you can have your sound
that game pass equivalent for vr right
right okay i see what you're going to
see
the hardware base uh okay i see where
you're going right now
going forward with them right and they
can that strategy can really work and
that 12 to 1300 proposition is act i'm
sold okay let me get at it because he's
been patient you got your hand up sir
i don't
i think they care about
the ps5
but i think they know
there for a while the only people really
buying this is the people really
dedicating the ps5 ecosystem because
they have a ps5 i think they know that
people aren't going to go out and buy a
ps5 just for psvr
like i think that they know that there's
obviously there's gonna be some on left
and right but i think they
they're relying more on the center the
people with the ps5 at that time
to buy psvr because they know this is
this isn't something that we're
expecting all the cells in six months
they're expecting to sell psvrs for the
next couple years so they're not going
to like launch something because ps5s
are impossible to get a hold of i think
it's a possibility that you know if it
comes out middle beginning of 2023
they start doing bundles with the psvr
too
with the ps5 to force people to buy like
that combined yeah to get a ps5
uh so i i think you are you know
no no i'm talking about i i'm like
what will end up happening is like
they'll put up that link that will okay
here's some ps5 solos we got 15 of them
right but we got a hundred we got the
husband
by the way
is 100 right
they'll use the shortage to their
advantage to push more units out
i see the vision because
let's say that things 1200
man you got it you got to spend 1200 for
a scalper right now
so you might as well just get the vr
with it
look let me get it because we going
super low at this topic um look uh hopes
of dreams for me
400 um hopes and dreams uh end of this
uh 2022
and um yeah i i i kind of gotta agree
with boom
as much as i'm hoping my gut is telling
me i don't like compassion i don't i
don't feel it i don't feel i hope i'm
wrong i hope i'm wrong i hope that they
have the the back compatibility for the
psvr one
base but i i don't know the track record
leads me to believe no so we'll see what
happens gotta get to the chat gotta boom
once we get attacked he wants to play
old games
dad follow us with chad says
flexing their muscles at cs with that
micro led tv lords that's the next level
let's get a gamonomics with the 40
rupees i believe psvr ii not being
wireless is a huge disappointment to him
okay and then we've got da da da da da
we're scrolling we're scrolling
chaney find out super chat if sony
charges 10 ounces for ps5 in features
and games will they charge an additional
ten dollars for vr features maybe twenty
dollars more question mark lucious
augustus finalist with chat the day the
facebook login goes away is the day i
get a quest i'll keep you posted brother
soon as i get the new word
facebook vlogging ain't this it's meta
logging
damn i have my brother killing something
dead it jumped on me damn it this damn
thing see if you're adding you help me
out it's up to ksrt i'm going to go past
him but ksanti jumped on me shot the
hard geek cheney he was like i think
boom already read this about the 399
with the camera the controllers i
believe you read that one already boom
right 4.99 bundled in i can't imagine
yeah he got that and then um
we are scrolling down i missed yourself
damn it i miss you uh 40 rupees again
gamonomic salute laws you guys think
psvr2 will come to pc
question yeah but it'll be modded just
like you can already use the psvr run pc
it's just that issue with the move
controllers with these controllers being
so much more like pc
vr somebody will hack it gotcha okay
hacked before we even have like time to
probably get a couple pc games in gotcha
okay i caught up i caught up okay asante
found your brother follow super chat to
my new vr brothers i hear folks talking
about triple a games time to get your
air link on rift store has a lot of
triple a games from insomniac and others
also shout out to ready at dawn they're
out there moving and shaking as well um
target should need two dollar super chat
playstation didn't tell you the cost so
you know it's high
mad will 20 super chat salute salute
brother i got a little emoji there looks
like you got something going on with the
quest um again ha gotcha we got you and
game announced okay we all caught up
cool let us keep it pushy did you say
the one that from
the 250 super chat from uh summit king
happy holiday lords respect you and all
and addicts
did you get the stitch one please thank
you here so far uh
let me just just keep going and i'll
figure out where exactly yeah thank you
brother because i missed i missed off
viciously right now oh all right so look
we got to get to it um
yeah ubisoft ubisoft plus an
announcement big announcement saying
they're coming to xbox and rainbow six
extraction launching on
game pass so it looks like shout out to
ubisoft looks like their official press
release they shouted they said that uh
raymond stratton will be a day one
edition for game pass and pc game pass
members allowing them to play on those
consoles and from the game's launch on
january 20th rainbow sixteen is already
part of game pass with available game
pass ultimate and pc game pass members
the same day giving pc gamers the chance
to squad up for even more rainbow six
actions with their friends so again they
did also talk about the ubisoft plus
component but i want to start off with
lord boom first on ubisoft we've had a
lot of discussions on this
boy boom had one of the more classic
clips on iop in reference to the sam
fisher goggles and all type of stuff a
classic clip so brother let's start with
you man like what are you thinking about
this news where's your head at ubisoft
plus potentially in rainbow six
extraction day and date
well extraction is huge and this goes
back to uh something that jeff grubb
said you know friends of the industry
friend of ours uh he said that microsoft
has billions
with an s
lined up for these big deals
right uh i think game path has become
the new exclusive
i think that and and when you step back
from the council war shenanigans and the
twitter turns into
microsoft is doing it right
uh sony is uh focusing in on those
square games that are locked in these
two-year deals and microsoft is like
okay hold my beer as i have all of these
dozen games from all these big aaa bombs
launching into game pass day and date
and that's costing them money and they
have money set aside for that seeing
rainbow six is a surprise rainbow six
extraction uh i think is gonna it's
gonna be big for it because leading into
this there wasn't a lot of hype a lot of
people don't understand what this game
is
right it's it's it's completely off the
rails when you talk about rainbow six
uh how often am i gonna play it i i
don't know because i'm still waiting for
rainbow six vegas three
um
i loved rainbow six vegas one and two i
played it ridiculously both single
player and multiplayer um i don't know
if i'm gonna i'm gonna get into this but
people who love rainbow six and that's a
big big title
are gonna enjoy this and it's a big get
it's a it's it's a it's the first big
aaa bomb
for uh 2022 for game pass so it's a it's
a big gag
uh as for ubisoft plus let's get it man
this is this is this is huge this is
huge because it's been on pc i've been
calling for it you've been calling for
it um
i know that there's been some talk
people walked away a little disappointed
that well how come you know there's
going to be a separate price well
i'll just say this how much
do you expect this is a business folks
you know we understand that these
companies make these moves and they do
you know the movers and shakers of the
industry it is a business they have to
make money
if they told me that it was ten dollars
a month to get ubisoft games which i'm a
big fan of their stuff
and we know that they put out at least
six games per year so just do the math
if you're going out and spending 50 60
70 on these games day one you're not
waiting for them
you are saving a ridiculous amount of
money for your 120 per year it's two
it's the cost of two games
and you're getting all of the dlc
in there that's something else that
you're getting in there and you're
getting their back catalog so it is a
it's a huge win and it's a big get for
microsoft like i said
shout out to jess corden uh of windows
central and the xbox two uh podcast
he wrote directly to xbox oh well i
think yeah the tweet was
my god microsoft it's only january
and they're dropping these these bomb
news and i and i think that this is the
prelude to what's coming microsoft is
not letting off the gas phil dominus
maximus aurelius spencer understands
that they must control the narrative
they did it in 2021 and they are
continuing in 2022
i think this is a big get
it is an incredible
line in the sand drawn by microsoft for
this year and i think it's going to be
big i think people are going to jump on
it
i know that some people are suggesting
it might be one of those uh additions to
your xbox game pass ultimate i mean they
haven't said it but i think it's going
to be a i believe they said it's going
to be a separate charge okay but will
they give you a discount that's the
question now it now on pc it's 15 a
month right we know that it's 15 which
is i don't think it's bad for what
you're getting personally
though you think we're doing it see
that's the thing
maybe they drop it to 10 a month if
because i think this is going to be a
separate service i think if even if you
don't have xbox game pass and you want
to sign up for the 15 a month no problem
okay what if you
already have game pass what if you're
gonna will they give you like a five
dollar discount because remember there
was a discount for ea um
play when it first came out
you could pay monthly or you pay for the
year and it was the discount so maybe
we'll see something like that i think
it's a big get for microsoft okay no
fair assessment lord acg you've been on
twitter very active in reference to this
subject
you'll be so flustered rainbow six
extraction what are your thoughts sir
so ea was separate well first of all i
just think they're figuring out another
way to get nfts onto the xbox and let's
hope i'm wrong right
um sorry i'm so anti-nft like
uh i am right there with you here's the
thing about ubisoft's deal ea was
separate for a while yes right but my
personal belief
and from what i've heard from other
people on how they just do deals how
microsoft does deals it's almost never
just the thing you're seeing
but my personal opinion is that it
really is a small amount about the
currently about the subscription being
there and more about it extra what is
extinction extraction
and other games from ubisoft
in the future
so
when microsoft comes together they can
say hey this game doesn't have a lot of
buzz around it let's do you want to
throw it on game pass do you want to
also be here and then they're like what
about what about what about right so my
personal belief is that's where they're
going and ubisoft has always been
the great [ __ ] of babylon
he got it right now i know you're going
i know where you're going sorry i know
what you're doing dlc with sony they do
all their own separate i don't see
ubisoft not talking to xbox about doing
their own expansions for stuff and i'm
not saying i want that but i could see a
lot of deals that we don't really see
now okay coming to fruition i don't like
the price and i don't like that it's not
merged just because hey yeah you know
that would be great it would be great to
get five dollars off yeah that would be
amazing um also i think the price is
pretty high for ubisoft they're not like
ea ea if you look at origin we can hate
ea all we want but they do a lot of
indie games yeah there's a lot of
support there where ubisoft is like it's
us hello
so i would like that to be a cheaper
price to be honest i would like it to be
i would have been happier around 9.99
you know i think that that would have
been a thing where people are like holy
crap i also agree with boom i don't
think there's i hope that there's never
been an idea that you have to pay for
game pass to get this i'm assuming
they're complete you can get ubisoft's
if you want and
and don't get game pass so overall
it's it's good news but i think what
we're seeing
is um is a future plan and additionally
i do just want to point out that
when it comes to the future when it
comes to the prices
microsoft does have these billions and
one of the things just anybody can do
this i'm not saying it's insider info
if you take a spreadsheet you start uh
finding out what so who and who paid for
what
um
exclusives yeah it is much cheaper to do
a game pass thing than it is to pay for
an exclusive microsoft found that out
with gta when they did the two
expansions so you have that as well
microsoft's got a ton of money they
could easily look at that also i
absolutely do know
for a fact microsoft is is looking
distinctly at back for blood style games
it's funny you say that because those
are identical type of games right
that that it's so i'm so glad you
mentioned that because it almost
fits a game pass template as far as
cooperative engagement out writers
outsiders
ubisoft wants it and microsoft wants
right so to me microsoft has been
showing their cards for a while right
back for blood was a weird one i
remember going back for blood on that's
odd but then i was like oh wait a minute
outriders is on there and then when i
started looking i'm like oh microsoft
if they are missing some core component
right microsoft just goes would you like
it on game pass
for a serious amount of money and even
if it's the same date you can bet a
developer is going to go of course we do
that's ridic and so last point i gotta
joke because you're on fire right now
because the the the ubisoft template
recently has been more in the live
service back right everything has been
there you know what i'm saying and i
could even think about older franchises
like a division or whatever you throw a
dlc and then you throw it in the system
and then boom now you get this shot in
the arm and microsoft can say hey look
look at these engagement numbers that
you you're having now in this title that
let's be honest may have been dormant
for a bit right but continuously i mean
even even even extinction like i said it
didn't have a lot of buzz now it does
even in my discord i hear somebody say
well it didn't look that good first of
all back for blood didn't look good now
that it's been patched i really like it
i really like it addict and i have
played it's a blast
i could see them
i could see them basically just saying
hey these are the openings we have you
and i don't think ubisoft
doing both
that to me means that there are more
plans if it was just ubisoft we'd be
like okay they're going steady they're
going steady yeah yeah they're going
steady they're a little over the shirt a
little over the shirt you know right
they're like
oh king's shaking his head i don't think
he agrees with me okay disagree
light petting no light betting yeah
well remember i'm old so different bases
i mean totally different things
this is good first base is pregnancy
these days
yeah i can't wait man i'm excited to see
what plans they have i don't love
exclusives but uh it is a part of life
all right and a part of life i need you
brother this is you
um yeah man what are you thinking about
this ubisoft plus potentially and and
then this rainbow six extraction day and
date
i think that
first off shout out to microsoft because
if nothing comes off of this and
they don't do any type of deal
it is one hell of a company to come out
there and be like we are so confident
with game pass you can bring your own
subscription service dog
inviting opponents to you
yeah that's funny
part of me feels like because of that
maybe there's more to the game past
theme but i don't necessarily think that
rainbow extinction is the like
the uh extraction is the thing because
like i look at that game and it looks
fun
but i i know hardcore six rainbow six
siege people yeah and none of them
wanted this
like for the most part they're like why
you gave me new operators
and you know i'm not saying that
you know extraction was going to do
anything or wasn't going to do anything
but i'm saying that i feel like ubisoft
might not be a hundred percent confident
in this because
for sure because
i wasn't confident in the beginning too
yeah so i i think they're like all right
but it is interesting that they
announced it in the same tweet
like it's not like it was something
where oh you know we're breeding plus
over in like a month later then like
yeah it's a deal man yeah
so
so it's interesting that they decided
because obviously if you announce that
you're bringing
if you're bringing that service
to the xbox and then at the end you're
like oh yeah
and uh extraction is going to be on uh
on gamepad's day and day clearly people
are going to connect those and there's
no way people at ubisoft making the
amount of money they do in the pr did
not see that coming so like thank you
for saying that good point i feel like
they they had to have thrown that energy
out there intentionally like if
regardless if it comes in
like i do think this might be a trial
phase they're like look man out of all
our games
we have
less faith in this game so it's like so
it's like here's our rook
bring me a queen back and we'll talk
we'll talk let's see what happens we'll
see what happened okay and i i think i
think you know
i think it's going to do well because
the thing is is like i think that
it's going to be like something rainbow
six siege came out and it didn't do well
at the game initially but if it was just
something like game pass outfits
so i think that i think that their
mindsets like we're not going to repeat
the same mistakes we made with six siege
we're just gonna go ahead
and partner with microsoft and be like
here take take the stepchild and bring
this back a raised child can i ask you a
question attic because you probably know
the reason why i never bring up rainbow
six siege with extraction is because not
only did they separate it into a
separate game they basically made it
pretty clear it's not rainbow six is it
the same devs because to me
i don't want the hardcore rainbow six as
much as i want new people plain
extraction and then if they also like it
but i mean it's not pvp which let's be
honest that's the juice of the toxic
community of rainbow six like they
they want to talk bad to you not a
zombie
i think that if you look at it from a
standpoint
uh let's
to my knowledge the operators are in
this game correct because i i saw like
ash and then it's oh okay okay i'm
pretty sure the operators i don't know
if they are i'm not gonna 100 uh you
know uh because i'm more of a rainbow
six siege like i would play this because
it's a gay pass shout out to microsoft
but you know
if the operators are in there with
someone in the comments section you're
going to correct me so do it now not
later because i want to be corrected on
the show so that changes if they are in
there to me
they are trying like sure they're trying
to get newer people because it's
something but you want to connect to
that operators i got you you are trying
to be like look
we're not going to give you any new
content on siege right now but we got
this other game for six they are
they are giving new content on siege
aren't they no i'm just talking about
right now like when this game comes out
because i don't think
they are saying my people are operators
are in the game oh
that's big because i saw it you get that
pvp connection those people love those
operate that basic list rainbow six
siege we talk about one of the greatest
comeback stories ever right from from
how they from
for honor dude mortal kombat is one of
the greatest remember or not
but remember when modern um warfare one
of them pissed people off and they had
steam pages going we will not buy this
game and then when you went there day
one they were all playing the game don't
play the game i mean i got like
i got like 20 days in sick of rainbow
six siege like i really enjoyed that
and i'm a play extinction because uh
extraction because
i really enjoyed the concept of that
like like i like defense tower games if
that makes sense i like like boarding
stuff up i like that type of game play
so i think that's going to work well in
there because let's be real here like
when did you do the defense attack mode
uh in rainbow six siege you already have
the foundation for that type of
you know that that gameplay game pass
and the reason why we're saying
extinction is second extinction is
identical to these and it is on gameplay
so you have you have i think that's
where i keep bringing extinction up and
that makes sense there is a game called
extinction let's talk to the king what's
going on how we feeling you got your fur
on is this what it's about
oh what we got fraud alerts with this
not y'all oh oh okay i told dudes last
march that ubisoft was coming up
you don't remember all told dudes last
march that ubisoft was coming to game
pass don't act like
my voice
you had absolutely zero conviction
behind your words um
picked the can up through down the line
and said from lobster back i got you
didn't i tell you that i told you that i
told you i'm standing behind that part
when when it happened the patch comes
out and it's not in game pass then
you've got my knees okay that's it
all
right
so i told dudes that ubisoft was coming
and i think the biggest hang up because
okay so they have the little meetings a
little right they have the meetings in
uh january as soon as everybody comes
back from holiday and stuff like that
whatever was on the table they get right
back to business like before you said
right now
yeah well fourth quarter business right
yeah going in this is fourth quarter
business getting ready to roll into
first quarter business um
this stuff was tail end stuff yeah i
think they couldn't nail down
um
you playing game pass
i think they couldn't nail it down okay
because remember when ea access and for
a lot of people that don't know there's
a there's an ea pro yeah that's not in
gamepad correct right not the highest
end that's not the day-to-day one that's
they day and date get busy and everybody
keeps saying oh i wish ea does day and
date they do but in any game
also remember they had ea access on the
microsoft platform
uh not the playstation platform right
for a long period of time before they
put it in game pass
when it before taking the game pass it
went to playstation they put ea access
on playstation
then they came right back around and got
another bag from microsoft and put it
inside game pass yeah that is true this
is the same strategy that you you play
ubisoft is going to use babylon
situation
yeah first first what they're going to
do
is
they're going to put uh
you you you plus ubisoft plus in there
first right
for the first year they're going to get
all the suckers to pay you the 15
we're in right we're good we're
fantastic we're in we don't care we're
getting all your stuff
right it's not going to go on
playstation just yet
it's all the best that's twirling
after they do they deal
they're going to send
you play
over to playstation
they're going to get their second bag
they're gonna give you a strip yeah
they're gonna give you a stripped down
version not the day and date stuff okay
that's gonna go inside game pass
and that's gonna be no extra cost no
stuff just like ea access
it's gonna be in it's gonna fit in there
and this is how ubisoft triples up their
bag
it doesn't hurt anybody
you know this is actually good business
because it doesn't make sound business
sense for them to put uh you play inside
game pass and cut out all that money
that they could be making whatever
initially it was crazy to what if well
the bag is not as crazy as that they're
gouging you anyway by putting our our
wheels on your on your console we're
putting our wheels over there anyway
okay we're going to charge you 15 bucks
anyway
and then we can get another bag from
playstation and then we can come right
back in and get on your game pass that
you love so much and get another bag
question there's no doubt that whole
thing question before i give it
what if microsoft says no
you can't have your separate service in
on our platform and it has to be already
agreed yeah i'm just i'm just curious if
there was anything no see what the value
proposition is the ecosystem on
microsoft that's the biggest thing
i've seen people talk about it i've seen
people say wow it's a complete uh uh 180
from when i had a xbox one
to now this thing is pretty much done
right in how they're handling the user
interface the ecosystem uh how
everything is because remember when we
got the xbox one
we didn't really have party chat all the
way we didn't have netflix and stuff on
this stuff you know this stuff is was
really thought out ahead of time it was
the easiest console that i've ever
hooked up in my life i hooked it up with
my phone i got you at it and everything
was there so
i i honestly believe
that it's going to take a period of time
but it's all contingent on how much
ubisoft wants to gouge the market and
make as much money as possible because
they're in the business of making money
anything away for free
you face it go
i think king is on to something when it
comes to that but i do think that
their
models are different ea
i don't think that you'll ever see
ubisoft plus whatever they like to call
it go to game pass but i do think you'll
see
ubisoft and xbox work more together and
you'll see more of those games come to
game pass maybe not all of them
but
it's no secret ubisoft's kind of going
away from the traditional games they
want to make everything games as a
service
and that type of model works the best in
a subscription service like game pass so
it doesn't make sense to everything like
the next assassin's creed that's
probably not going to get past day and
day
but something like something like
assassin's creed
not an assassin's creed uh you know
rainbow
those make more sense because you want
to get as many people in there and
buying those microphones
okay yeah and i think you're going to
see more of those type of games like i i
love that one game that um
the greek mythology game what's that
game odyssey
uh no not all phoenix was rising phoenix
was amazing i love that game
fantastic yeah so good i don't see games
like that going to game pass maybe i
don't see you know the next um
splinter cell whatever whenever that
decides to come in uh i don't see that
going over but i do see
i do see them putting the base models
for some of their
subscriptions because they are like look
we're going to get that back from
microsoft
but we're going to introduce so many
more people to that brand that we're
going to get more money in the long run
through microtransactions all right let
me jump in this is fun um shout out to
king
it's about time ubisoft we've been
waiting
we've been waiting this is the the most
first kept secret that mostly you know
it was so long that we thought it it
wasn't yeah
most people went back i guess not i
guess not right but to king's point and
as you know hcg you've been on fire with
this as well you know to king's point
you know technically it is still fourth
quarter right technically you were still
in that in that range so it they didn't
miss so to speak jordan
exactly it did miss that last joint but
um you know as far as extraction you
know
you know i'm with boom in the sense that
you know this to me nacg the sense that
this to me fits the game pass for me
yeah right four player cooperative pve
experience you know you can have fun you
can have some micro transactions or some
live service action if you choose like
you can have fun but if you want to look
good if you want to get that wallet
if you want to look good
you can't see yourself but if you want
to look good to other people
right
it's so weird
they they passing that like
legit mentality of life onto people it's
like and you're like
their own games by the way do that right
where you get the stuff and you you have
like a red suit and that's it and then
you look at their micros and it's like
they got you know everybody looks
awesome you know that's that's amazing i
hadn't thought about that so real so
real salute i think this is good i think
it's good for ubisoft you know obviously
and then you know i'm going to probably
say no cat ears please no caddy i'm
gonna probably say some things that's
gonna upset king but i'm gonna have to
say it but oh look
this is the thing
let's you know for me
i look at 2021 and i look at the year
xbox had i'm like okay
strong
yeah right this is how you do it you
close the year just tremendous age of
empire psychonauts you know um
forza horizon halo top of the year you
had outriders and and what you call it
to kind of hold you down mlb to show to
hold you down from the game pass
perspective
but i look at 2022 y'all and i got to be
real
playstation's coming when you look at
that lineup so far right and you got the
the uncharted you got the the seafood
you got the horizon you know that's not
to mention stuff they announced right
you got gran turismo you have forspoken
we don't know when exactly got a war but
we would assume hopefully right yeah i
got to kick this next year but we
hopefully i mean hopefully but if it
comes out in 2022 this year that is a
tremendous lineup it could be a killer
year right now god of war horizons by
itself
they're gonna dominate the zeitgeist
regardless if they both dropped this
year right so now clarify i don't think
it's coming out this year i don't do it
you with king but if it does regardless
it's still interesting
yes correct so
anyway the point i'm saying is this i
look at the xbox live right now y'all
know i am star field ride or die that's
my joint i'm going hard in the paint
that's bethesda a team sci-fi sign me up
right but still someone knows we still
gotta see more about it red four we hear
about we hear about forza motorsport 7
right but other than those
there's a huge top of the first year
that got to be accounted for when sony's
about to drop these games and to me
what you need to do is moves like this
where you have to bolster game pass game
pass what king said eloquently like
last year when out writers and mlb this
show
they felt like they were xbox exclusives
to the mindset because it feels like
you're getting away with something
you're getting it for free you had
people that owned both platforms playing
it all next time exactly so to me in
every month without put it like this
every month there's no first party
offering from xbox game studios you need
to have a third-party game that is huge
in the service me personally i'm going
next for elden ring if possible
you know if there's any way i doubt it's
probably even doable but if there's any
way that you need those games that
dominate the zeitgeist that you go okay
that's a game pass oh yeah definitely
you know what i'm saying then each month
that might be one of the games that they
really dropped the bag right that's the
one
on that yeah
yeah
king don't like it but i'm telling you
right now
it's gonna be big bro what i'm saying
rings
go ahead kid then i got it and i got acg
i think they need to drop the bag on oh
you say it because it doesn't fit the
format you don't okay there's no
multiplayer
on gameplay witch queen
renew renew the destiny 2 which
i think that i think i think that boat
doesn't sail
i think something happened there i think
that deal ran out i think they looked at
the halo bag and said get on before
it's a wrap though like you spit in the
same bars dudes they really uh your
engagement numbers ain't really worth it
but it is still in the top ten but check
it out every time something comes out
people leave destiny we'll be back later
yeah adam just said yo i'm gonna come
back i'm gonna finish this up do some
witch queen being there for a good two
uh two weeks and then i'm out like so
you know they look at this engagement
they're like
how much why are we paying so much money
for these dudes nah just if the destiny
dudes are gonna be there we still
purchase the stuff i still pay the forty
dollars for this stuff it's still gonna
be i think they're gonna spend the money
on different stuff new things that
extraction stuff is a smart idea four
players you've got to do this gonna do
before i give a daisy what are you gonna
do in february when eldon ring horizon
forbidden west
drop what are you going to do to combat
that
ain't um in a subscription over there on
playstation you gotta go buy that
seventy dollars get it on or whatever
the price is the same exclusive but
what game they'll we don't know they
surprise us every time sometimes you
look over and you're like what that's in
there how the hell that happened so we
don't know exactly what the plan is very
true so let's see the rebuttal for the
hit okay i see she's been patient his
hands up continue no i like that i like
that dude i figured the hand i love the
feature it's dope it works great um i
just wanted to say that uh we all
talk about like the titles and the
exclusives mattering and stuff like that
and they definitely do but if you look
at the i was just doing the math in my
head if you look at three game pass
owners together for a month you're at
the cost 45 game something like that and
i would assume microsoft is looking at
these occasional exclusives even if they
sell eight million and still go on well
our game game passes every month
and so they're probably not as worried
as maybe some of us are okay i would
agree with you lord i'm not i mean i
like xbox but i'm not like
i'm not i don't have an xbox centric
podcasting like even that wasn't working
for me it's just like the idea all the
time some especially me because i'm
pretty caustic towards some of their
ideas
and so the idea that they're of what
they have to offer i agree with you that
2022
2021 is when microsoft's uh when did
microsoft do mass effect um bioware
they did mass effect yeah they did
a bungee game and they did bizarre they
had the three b's and i think it was
2009 with shane kim if i remember right
where it was just it was ridiculous it
was like three huge blockbusters same
thing will happen with sony but eldon
rings xbox too true and somebody will
look and go hey i'll buy the xbox
version because we'll see how the tech
goes keep in mind acg like they by
default get the stuff that goes into ea
play too
so like because they're an ultimate like
when mass effect drops they still get a
claim that's coming the game away yeah
continue so i was just going to say i
actually agree with lord
with cognito completely that
it's it's a quiet
so far microsoft does though have a
tendency now to announce and release
some titles
more quickly and that's something that
even phil spencer has said so it would
be nice to see a surprise but i agree
with you and we haven't had a lot of
leaks i heard one leak and it's dead i
can't get any like confirmation on it
and yet we still do know that there's
some discussion behind the scenes on all
kinds of stuff like metal gears and
stuff you know like from konami versus
from uh what's his name and so you have
there's some stuff out there but i agree
with you this year is
it's weird because i i was so confused
by last year i thought i thought the
flight game was the year before oh there
were so many games like i said i forgot
to even mention that yeah yeah when
somebody tells me exclusives we just
have this argument the discord
somebody's like exclusives are sony's
bag and then i was like well wait not
for last year i mean at the minimum you
could make an argument right but
microsoft has one big issue
their formula that they apparently want
is four player or three-player co-op
online sony is third person
now microsoft tried to do it with x with
rise to the tomb raider they paid for
the exclusivity and by the way that soul
actually did well
i'm still surprised microsoft has not
figured out a way to get a third person
action
huge that is what i'm actually expecting
to see on the xbox
welcome to the club brother i've been
hashtagged just wanted for everybody
they throw stones at me
it's it's got it's got to happen it's
good at some point and i just don't know
who it'll be yeah you know and and to
acg's point man he's right
he's 100 right and wouldn't it be ground
shaking
industry stopping
if it was an elden ring
remedy because i still want them to work
together but yeah you're right if it was
elden ring it won't be i actually
personally feel like remedy is a better
fit for sony
no no no it's not that it's just like in
terms of studio i feel like oh how they
work for them more than not
shout out shout out to 10 will move on
well don't talk to the bend developers
then because they don't agree with you
look i'm feeling about talking because i
want to get i don't talk about that yeah
we're going to get to it right now good
transition good trick good segue and
plus we got bulma limited time but we
have last thing i want to say in
reference to that point was just i want
to see what happens like king saying
with the going steady into the ubisoft
potential
if they for the streets if they from
babylon if they from babylon we get it
just an alley that's all we need
oh shout out to the mr irish men with
the five pound uh super chat happy new
year's gents and lords helping square
enix burn in the timed exclusive nft
hell of their own making where's my
final fantasy remake xbox port at all
right
he feels strong like sony they keep
spending the money to delay it damn
remember for 19 months lord bronze
salute no one is going to play full
praise for ub plus when they can buy
their games half off a month after they
release
all right and i think i'm caught up no
i'm not on the mismatched stuff but at
it you had to help me donald taco 10
super chat ps lineup looks but it's not
competing with xbox for the simple fact
that even if playstation's exclusive
lineup is a little better with 32 day
one game pass drops already confirmed it
won't be close so you're talking about
volume all right donna taku again follow
super chat also nintendo's exclusive
lineup is looking better than both as
long as breath of the wild 2 comes out
but y'all don't want to have that
conversation switch covered in height
listen 480 odd 10 eyeballs up
damn it
switch cover their hotdog taco i see you
boy i see you
and uh alvin shout out to the member for
six month or lord bronze they should try
that for the evil west game
that debuted at the tgas for a third
party person action game and attic you
gonna have to save me because i know i
miss people i am sorry y'all i'm i'm not
the same without we are forgetting
stalker real quick is stalker two this
year certainly is april i believe
put the crest up he is the winner here
for my fantasy football roses cog he is
the winner of the iop nfl fantasy
football championship i got to give him
his role he beat me on route to the
playoffs so he he's rubbing it in salute
to you and his name on um the fantasy
league is final fantasy vi is the goat
cog shut up so salute to you you get
your bars off one time only
absolutely man good championship we'll
do it again next year guys did you get
the fidel hargachi as a reminder psvr
came out at 3.99 yeah you got that okay
help me help me bro uh the 40 uh gamer
racks uh
definitely
uh then victor with the happy new years
lords two and then we got the butter
ball with the two dollars super chat got
a name the next tlc tv after king ah see
i missed a good one too thanks eddie
that was good no
[Laughter]
what else we all caught call it the king
sixty five hundred are we caught up sir
no
yeah we are yeah we're caught up okay
let's get it man cuz i wanna set boom
off with this because we got him on
limited time and i don't want my man's
back hurting you know we got to protect
the bat
anyway look so let's get into it like a
lot of talk right now in reference to go
sushima eight million so also sony was
able to put out the tweet references
celebrating the success of the studio
shout out to sucker punch you know doing
their thing big title and then
we've had some interesting discussion
and this is in reference to the days
gone developers also claiming on twitter
you know that um let's let's let me
quote him first and he said shout out to
jeff ross again of ben's new game
director of days gone ben he said pretty
much at the time i left sony and this
was right after the ghost of our sushima
talk um he said
um after the tweet excuse me from us off
he said after the time i left sony days
gone had been out for a year and a half
and a month and sold over eight million
copies it's since gone on to sell more
and then a million plus on steam local
studio management always made us feel
like it was a big disappointment then um
i believe shout out to uh david jaffe i
believe he also went on david jaffe's
our show in reference to kind of talk a
little bit more and you know again about
the 8 million thing because a lot of
people came up to kind of either refute
or maybe say if it was incorrect and he
put out another tweet and this was to
say i stand by my numbers so kind of
allowing him to say kind of a line in
the sand in reference to
i guess his opinion on how he's been
tweeted in reference to um
not he has been tweeted but the studio
in reference to allowing days gone to
have a sequel that seems to be the talk
of the town so let's get it boom you are
up
brother what do you think here you know
in reference to first the ghost yoshima
tweet announcing a success sony praising
the success and then the days gone you
know different ways king laughing
developers saying that you know
we he didn't feel that they were
celebrated during their you know the
tenure there for days going in the same
way goes to sashimi was
awesome well go to tsushima was my game
of the year
it's probably one of my favorite games
uh especially the new ips for sony it
i mean whenever whatever the sequel is
going to be it is going to completely
melt your face off in the next ever you
know iteration of it when it comes to
the playstation 5.
what they were able to capture
on that on that console is still to this
day completely unbelievable
uh and in in in typical sony way they
just dominated a single player story
driven adult themed game that just
looked
gorgeous and played incredible
so i saw the tweet we talked about this
on breakfast with boom um and you know
the numbers that apparently these uh the
head developer of bend uh pulled was uh
from trophies
and he got the eight million number that
eight million people in fact played
their game which their game was
i'll put it to this way why it's a shame
that we're not going to get a days gone
too is very similar to what happened
with uncharted one uncharted one was a
good game but it had a ridiculous amount
of issues it wasn't a great game but
sony gave that studio a chance and
uncharted 2 is still one of my top three
playstation 3 games of all time i
absolutely i've beaten that game half a
dozen times absolutely loved it so much
um
here's the thing
seeing this uh sony gets in their
feelings and they prop up who they want
to prop up i was very surprised and
obviously he's no longer he left ben's
studio so he's not working for sony so
he can be forthcoming in honest or
earnest if you will and and he obviously
is uh feeling a type of way that um you
know
his studio that put out a good game uh
there were some issues it it doesn't and
i think that's where we have to
understand the difference here
goes to tsushima
launched perfect i don't recall there
being any problems with it
and maybe i missed oh now you're talking
about yeah you're right from so your
argument is from a technical level at
launch we can fairly say goshima was
more polished yeah ten days ago it
worked okay you know you didn't have him
riding a horse with no horse right you
had that happen unfortunately with days
gone you were riding a motorcycle and
you were like this and there's no one
you know so it learned it launched with
some issues they did if you play it now
it's really good
my problem with days gone was i thought
that it was too open world for its own
good okay they could have shrunk it just
a little bit and it would have been a
great game i do wish that we would have
gotten a second one the foundation was
so strong that i believe the second one
would have been oh my god it would have
been so much better
so you know we we we have heard though
okay that's not the only game that they
pitched they pitched an open-world
resistance game
as well and they were denied they also
pitched um an open-world siphon filter
and they were denied that as well they
pitched a couple of games right so i
don't know if sony or sie had the
confidence
in ben studios to deliver another aaa
experience that could potentially cost
30 40 50 million dollars to make
and it just doesn't sell well
um is eight million game eight million
playstation players
a good number
how many of them bought because remember
that game was given away for free
in playstation plus oh collection right
yeah yes yeah collection
so
we have to ask exactly i i know his
numbers are from the the trophies and
the trophy numbers don't lie right so
eight million sold for goshima versus
well eight million people have played
see there's there's some there's some
conversation in between there when again
we have to get into the let's talk about
business
they sold eight million copies of ghost
tsushima right that's that's what
they're saying right that's a lot a lot
of that's a lot of sales for a new iep
i actually think i'm actually
disappointed that it wasn't more i'd
love to see 10 15 million kind of get
into the spider-man range the god of war
range because the game is so good right
i mean that year that it came out
i still can't believe that um last of us
two scored better than this i thought
less of us two they should reverse the
scores one should have gotten eight one
should have gotten a tent
because gosushima is by by by any
stretch
i i
absolutely had a big problem with the
last of us i don't know i
and i was so disgusted with it that i
just was like you know whatever i got i
guess that's it
so there you go but um i am um not
surprised by this comments um
i think it it's
what does it really say about sony i
don't think it really puts them so much
in a bad light to be honest with you
because
you know they they are who they are
there were some problems days gone
didn't launch like ghosts of shima if it
would have and they would have given
them this slack then there's a problem
so you think more from the technical
aspect and more from the
metacritic response is where you feel
sony is more justified to
kind of say okay look
this is why we're celebrating
goshenshima more you know very versus
days ago okay yeah okay i i i think that
the overall
uh start of each of the ips one was
rocky one was good and one continued to
grow while the other one was stayed
rocky for a while it's a good game now
play it
no before i give it actually i have one
more question for you but what about
the mindset or the idea of
being afforded a sequel right because
that seems to be the point of dispute
here which is you know whether or not it
was pitched or not or whether or not
they thought it wasn't going to be able
to you know even be listened to for a
pitch and then obviously we know about
the jason try article and and what's
going on in ben's studio and you know
again i'm not in those rooms i'm just
going by the reporting so i'm just you
know the reporting was kind of like look
you know they
felt pigeonholed into
doing a last of us remake as opposed to
being confident enough to wise kings
find to pitch a daze gone sequel right
and
that seems to be the point of contention
so in reference to the sequel park boom
do you believe
daze gone deserves it or are you like
hey no i mean you guys kind of came out
the gate rocky and
you know it is what it is go go get on
that last
i'll just try to get your position oh
that's it oh no i think they should
actually absolutely should have been
afforded the the ability to make a
sequel okay the foundation is there
there should have been a lot of that
sony didn't have the confidence yeah i
think that's okay that comes down okay
fair enough acg let's get it day's gone
success versus go sushima success what
do you what are you feeling about this
whole controversy
um
so the the little thing about sales and
trophies those could be used games blah
blah blah so i don't you know i whatever
numbers are spouted out the yeah the
difference is is that one's a good game
and one is not and like i mean not to be
rude but days gone had such a poor
reception by everyone who reviewed it it
was and by the way i had day one i don't
know what was going on you saw people
being like you didn't have day one no we
did a couple days prior i got to test it
it might have only been a day or two
prior but i still tested still had
issues we see videos everywhere of it
like it's not it's not magic it's not
something that's a lie days gone was a
generic zombie game
and the idea of making a sequel of a
generic zombie game when you can make a
sequel of a samurai game that did
excellent and no one had done before
including assassin's creed which has
been sitting on japan
longer than thank you
most invasions it's ridiculous you're
just sitting there going like dude you
know they're holding that you know they
hold you they know ubisoft is like when
we're in deep [ __ ] yeah here comes
assassin's creed it's probably done man
it's probably done
you're waiting for the books to go down
continue yeah so yeah i just stopped
it's like the forza in japan too
everyone wants everything
but uh i'm i'm day's gone got patched
right and i've played it through on the
pc and it was much better
however
the technical problems having been gone
it was not super enjoyable it was
enjoyable it just wasn't
it wasn't near goes to sushima even if
you look at it from like uh
just looking at it it just wasn't the
same
it wasn't the same kind of experience so
and then this thing in no way shape or
form ever
ever in history should it ever be said
that you deserve a sequel i've never
even heard that that's the dumbest
that's like a super bowl winner
returning and being number one again
that makes no sense talk about it do not
companies if they deserve a sequel what
if we already have another company
working on a game that would overlap
should you just get a sequel even though
now we'll be fighting it's it's that is
the kind of stuff that people who don't
track games and don't track how things
are actually even done would say do they
deserve a sequel
no do they deserve to be able to say we
want to make a sequel absolutely okay
absolutely and they went to sony maybe
and said we want to make a sequel and
sony said no that's quite literally how
i can ask my mom for money doesn't mean
she has to get it
all right all right you going in you go
i gotta i gotta jump in i gotta i gotta
play devil's half okay i got him jc joe
he could go hard he go all right but
what about the minds i hear what you're
saying brother everything you're saying
is logical in fact i get it it's the
real world right
my question is you know we
me and king have had this even movement
discussion which is an addict which is
okay
there are some series or franchises
where the first iteration is solid but
there are enough issues you're like eh
but
man the potential is there right the
potential and the question i have for
you is a sense of
i feel again correct if i'm wrong that
sony's always done a good job of
nurturing right so where it's like okay
the first shut up kick the first
iteration may not knock it out the box
like i'll try to what may have not
knocked it out the box right
but you were afforded a sequel not
granted i hear what you're saying with
business i hear nothing's guaranteed
everything you're saying is logical
right but i just felt like
maybe just maybe right i don't know if
it was pitched see that's the other
point of contention here was it it was
specially it was pitched because i'm
here
i actually believe that it was okay he
said it was pitched okay i just went
because i said it never went above the
people be uh in front like i guess every
like you know every studio has that
executive that reports to someone above
them
he never went past that person okay okay
that's all i want to ask i mean i get it
what you say
look i get that's real life i get it
yeah i mean
it's not only that but um i like you
know sony first of all i don't at all
believe the nurturing thing and i never
have
that's just because i've talked to
people who work and they're like none of
these companies are really as nurturing
as you may be yeah we had chris cadella
chris grinnell said the same thing about
sony liverpool in the same yeah exactly
um but overall the thing about
so let's say you're pushing pitching
this game and you're like hey man this
game that didn't you know didn't perform
with a [ __ ] on a console we want to do a
second one come on acg damn it it didn't
perform worth a [ __ ] it was terrible on
by the way
not only in comparison to other
first-party games
that was terrible in comparison to other
third-party games that released poorly
that game was not i like sony's dude
spider-man's one of my favorite games of
all time i will tell you right now that
game wasn't even in the same
millionth of a league of spider-man
additionally it was the character was
pretty boring i like the actor i think
he does a good job that character and
that continuation of the story would not
grab me if you said hey guys more
zombies
freakers come on
i got the horde system which was great
but when you tell me that there's like
another story to be told there i don't
jump on that as quickly as something
else now i didn't know this thing about
a remake or whatever so they were forced
to make that's the allegedly that's
what's uh elastic okay so that
is that's money talking right somebody
looked and said this is maybe won't make
it this is turn around is quicker that
does suck as a creator you want it right
as a creator you want to make your
sequel
i would rather have ben try over
with something else i don't
i would never say
that developer doesn't need to be able
to make another game okay but i would
say
oh is that what yeah you were scared
my developer's heart was hurt
well what i'm saying is that game
you know let it sit for a while maybe
you do look at it later but i still
don't think just let it sit for a while
means you automatically get it it
doesn't that that's real life that's
real life it's real life and
they sh they per they did something
and they tried hard and it didn't
it
nearly as much as or not last of us yeah
less of us too
nearly as much um
but i think the remake was a good
probably financial plan and maybe kept
him solvent too that's another thing man
yeah that's good point like how what's
your turn around hey looking at the
money we need to turn around in a year
and a half we don't need to turn around
in three years to your defense if
devil's advocate damn it i don't need a
defense i mean well i'm just being i'm
defending
i'm being a big sad developer car so my
question is i mean my point was
you're making great points
in reference we don't know
the budget yeah
right how much did it cost what if they
was wild expensive right what if they
were doing just ps5 only all right if
they were they wanted to do cross gin
and honest to god guys that game pushed
when it's patched it plays pretty good
now on the ps4 and
pro
all
it's like sitting there going like we're
going to fall apart any second
um so yeah we have no we have no clue
yeah yeah we don't know that and we
don't know how long as far as at least i
don't know remember the uh how long it
took them you know what if the window
was you know four to five years or
whatever yeah and i'm not like a lot of
other people get mad at a dev and are
like oh this bad this other game was bad
so i'm for sure not gonna buy their next
game that doesn't they should be able to
make whatever they want i just don't
hold on to that for very long because
people get better too you hire in people
who have a talent on your next thing and
yeah not fair enough attic let's get it
you need it
i
i think i'm kind of
yeah let me just start throw this out
there uh for the first two years of
development for days gone according to
bloomberg 28 million dollars
that's a pretty substantial amount back
yeah i'm small that's a lot i don't know
i just wanted to want to throw it out
there because i know the numbers came
out but listen
i don't want yeah well you got it i got
something blue
i have a good one with you yes
definitely
the mu and of course my brothers love
you guys very much love to chat and
we'll be talking soon
have a good one enjoy your sunday man
always great to see you man boomstick
excel my brother have a good one man
i'll talk to you
no doubt all right addict let's get it
man day's gone versus the ghost you see
my success story
i feel like if you play i played a
little bit of days gone but i dropped it
just as quick as i started playing it
i've what i've been told for the most
people and i don't know if you can
relate on this acg because i'm confident
you played it but
if
from everyone i told said that it's got
had serious pacing issues like serious
pacing issues yeah
and i feel like that will kill a game
quicker than anything will
where it's like you've stayed long past
why i'm willing to play
it and it's like you're not doing
anything different and
i do feel like when you play gosu
tsushima
the quality is on a different level so
it would make more sense where
you know sure the metacritic wise ghost
wasn't even like high high as far as
like comparing to other games
but
it had a better reception to the actual
community like everyone loved that game
it actually felt like it was one of
those scenarios where he was like the
media got this wrong it deserved to get
hired you know what i'm saying so
like i do understand but at the same
time
i do feel like if you do make a game
and it did have a good structure and a
good way to go up i do feel like
maybe you should have funded another
day but at the same time
i don't blame sony for being cautious on
their portfolio
why
okay you we gave you the opportunity to
make a zombie game
that we already got one free called
blasters we got freakers yeah i get it
like tomato tomatoes
like it's like it's like we we gave you
something similar then we we shouldn't
have really done that because we already
got something around that vein but we're
gonna let you rock
and you brought us this it didn't do the
greatest
but it's just like my point is like you
brought us this it might not have been
the greatest
but it's just like last of us two went
out there
why should i fund something else to do
something else that we're already doing
better
so it's just like i don't blame sony for
being cautious on their portfolio
especially when you look at microsoft
having diversity in every damn genre you
can think of we should be clear we keep
saying sony but it sounds like it didn't
even get out of ben's studios
but i feel like like
yeah go ahead you feel like it would
have or something no it's not that i
feel like the reason it didn't
is because
the people above
ben studio knew
that it like it was like literally the
temperature to rule we know what we know
the temperature today you're feeling
this well think about it this way a
sports coach will win a super bowl and
it'll be a messy game and a good coach
will be like dude we won but you guys
ethan suck
like you guys are and so what i'm
wondering is what happened was it it did
it lacked polish and i bet you
internally they were disappointed i will
tell you this i don't think any
developer true developer would release
that game and go i'm happy
i don't even that person who made this i
bet deep down inside you're like it has
a bunch of issues and that can be sony's
fault too maybe they pushed them we
don't know
but i think when you look at this you
just basically look at it and say hey
man we tried right and it didn't work
out which by the way isn't the first
time a game hasn't worked out the reason
why this is brought up is because later
a randomly complete game got a headline
which i will say that was odd that it
was like people celebrated the sales of
one game and somebody ran
hijacked the tweet to say
our game that didn't release as good
and had a bunch of technical issues we
were told by our management it was bad
and it was like okay
but you sort of shat on somebody's
christmas not to be honest what you're
saying in a sense so let's let gos have
their moment instead
like if you tweeted your birthday and i
was like well my birthday's tomorrow
good
this is the favorite sun complex stuff
you know i don't even think it's the
favorite they didn't like ben they
didn't like ben okay so
everybody can sit there and act like i
noticed they stopped pushing the game
right before the game was going to come
out and it like went silent then then it
came out um
i didn't like what they were doing with
it how they were uh promoting the game
yeah true ghosts they were promoting the
hell out of it yeah all right so all
right
hi sean
[Laughter]
i see what you're doing yep
hi sean actually you know what's funny
did you guys watch cause i didn't talk
when you were talking
no no i just want to add this i just
want to add this okay bring this in the
conversation
the dude over there uh one of the leads
of ben's studio said the moment sean
left
days gone too was dead like the moment
he left him so regime changed
so again that happens again
like i've been saying for a long time
let's go hi sean
all right can i ask you a question king
yes yes about sean
sorry because i i don't know this
uh slang joke are you saying you like
shawn a lot and he's supportive
okay he's a daughter he's a bryan guy
i'm i'm a hell of a gym writing guy he's
about to buy i love what jim does cold
calculating no emotion
europe messed up
get out of here
oh my god
japan you messing up oh but you gave us
such a rapid rapper
you you're making demo games for our uh
[Laughter]
and you said all right we got this date
yeah but
concrete jungle thing and that's one of
the greatest games of all time so i
don't know man
but again
again i got you
i understand he said
y'all got the shot
numbers didn't look right the gym jim
don't want to hear that so the
temperature in the room is that he
that's right it didn't go past gold
jim don't like you
what you're going to do is you're going
to go fix this remaster that we got
going over here
because we got to get these numbers up
because this is actually this is a
producer
yeah exactly it's a business right this
is this is this is what he does he does
his numbers so if this was sean
hey sean
salute we would have gotta
this is the thing
that nurturing stuff that these dudes
this coddling stuff that these dudes
keep talking about that naughty dog and
and and oh they got a chance to make uh
uncharted because uncharted didn't chart
right the first one they got a chance to
make a two how come this okay you're
crying now
you had your one shot jim is a one-shot
dude
and people better not be saying that
because that is when there was no
competition at all yes we are in a whole
different ballgame if people are trying
to pretend the uncharted one to two
thing has any bearing on today xbox was
i mean even when they were doing well
with the 360. they sony's name just
it didn't matter where you were man
microsoft could have you saved babies
from floods and sony would have showed
up and been like do you like my blue
shoes
your blue shoes is crazy yeah you crazy
drop the baby
shoes and run off like a simpsons
cartoon
it's a different situation actually
is making bread
yeah so
you say eight million soul retweet that
send that out shout out to them they
make money jim likes that excuse me
coming through
this dude said y'all hold a second we
did eight mil they didn't like you
and then they're gonna have to go
through the to
to see how they first had to put your
game on free
right to get people to play the game
yeah collection yeah all right so now
this is my opinion of it yeah gotta go
for it
i still like eight million eyes on the
game yeah
right
no one deserves anything
you earn it yeah that's what you just
said you had your shot
you blew it
ghost of sashimi developers had they
shot too
they nailed it
now so if you're gonna go poo poo on a
day we did eight million yeah i feel
like i feel that yeah that was a bad you
take that in your chest you rub that in
your chest you hold that you take that
and you'll be like man we did 8 million
too they ain't like us but you also know
that you came in with warts and and
stuff with your situation
i can't tell nobody i can't i never
heard anybody say
ghosts
shipped
with all the flaws
that days gone did yeah right yeah
right so do you get a shot no you don't
deserve anything you get what you what
you earn this is a business so a lot of
you people out there crying
no they do not and i'm honestly gonna
say i stand by jim on this this is a
business move
and you're gonna be allocated to do
something else and right now please
don't pitch anything to me just do the
stuff that we asked you to do because
you're the studio right i'm the boss
i allocate the funds you're not getting
no funds right now no soup for you
until you understand this is what i want
you to do now i'm pretty sure if they do
that remastered really well
and it does really good numbers then
he'll look over and be like okay
all right i live 150 miles from these
guys so i'm just waiting for them to
show up at my desk
they go pull
i do want to point out that if this was
microsoft doing the same thing i think
i mean
when ryan mccaffrey said we need to pull
everyone off obsidian and we need to
pull everyone off everyone and help them
make elder scrolls six forcing studios
to make stuff they didn't want to do we
did hold ryan accountable for that
statement that that's not right that is
true so
the fact that they're pulling business
video on twitter is twitter oh okay yeah
i agree with that that kind of stuff i
do not like where one company gets a
weird
free free they just get a free pass on
some of the stuff that they do and say
and the other doesn't that definitely
happens right yeah so i am saying well i
do agree with king i'm with ryan
okay because i do feel like at the end
of the day
it makes no sense
that day's gone and last of us survi
live under the same roof you know what
i'm saying like
i do understand from a business aspect
right i understand that maybe they
should have got the opportunity to make
one right but i understand sony's
perspective that you had your shot right
to do something that we didn't really
need and you didn't really deliver it
100
so i don't really i don't really
i can't hate on them for saying maybe we
need to put days gone down so what
you're saying they decided to take the
clickers over the freakish
yes
can i just point out also that if you
look at last of us and you look at days
gone even patched the difference in
quality
we've not even yeah
yeah well i think we can all so like to
me
one's working and one's not and
microsoft wishes they had a days gone
because they got state of decay which i
like but let's be honest
it's the perfect name for a game because
that is the state it is always in gold
you're tweeting you tweet was loose
about that tweet i put a tweet out i got
a dm less than an hour later going like
that's pretty uh that's a pretty harsh
pretty harsh twitter there
so i sold it to the exchange look man
look uh everything y'all said it it's
it's common sense it's business
it it
i can't refute it i understand right
again i am biased
i am too close to the situation how are
you yeah way too close to the situation
you know for for us you know iop i know
king we get we clown a lot you know king
clowns a lot of time but you know for
for us i remember was it pax 2019 and um
you know getting a chance to just sit
down with ben studios and and really you
know go through days gone and the
mechanics and i like the freakers i like
the big horde mechanic now was it
ambitious was it trying to do a lot yes
you know um was it
something that yeah from a technical
standpoint i cannot even dispute what
acg is talking about it had issues you
know i remember the bike controls was
one of my major ones off the rip i was
like oh y'all got to fix this it was
like translating three languages before
it would turn yeah it was weird it was
doing too much you know it for sure for
sure i definitely now remember to king's
point when it came out on playstation
collection
and then we got the 60 frames bump and
i'm like oh okay there we go we got the
patches and stuff like that you know
look it's one of those things that again
no one is like hcg is right you are not
deserved right nothing is guaranteed to
say hey because you did this you
guaranteed that absolutely correct it's
just funny to me that
in the building this is my perception
right and they are this it's up to sony
this is the way they do business and
they have every right it's just
interesting to me i feel how much
metacritic does play a role in the
building unfortunately right and that's
where i stand i struggle i struggle
because you know i'm always going to i'm
biased i'm always going to be pro
developer i think these guys superheroes
i think they create these worlds that i
can't even dream i don't have any
knowledge of coding on that level to
create anything these guys create so i
look at something as like you plant a
flower and you're like all right you got
a little weather weathery leaf there and
whatever whatever but you know the
foundation the root the root was strong
you know i'm saying and granted the
business don't work like that they want
to see the numbers they want to see the
thing but
i just hate the metacritic influence and
because it can be manipulated right and
there are a lot of change that though
what you mean
all right so i talked on game on daily
yesterday on a system that can be
implemented in both
all consoles
um
you get to rate the game when you finish
the game okay and those games actually
and and that rating and i'm talking
about through the through the hardware
all guys i mean
you get a token you get a little code
or whatever that'll pop up and you're
able to rate the game right so they know
that you finish the game right they know
that you did the checks and balances all
the way through the game right
and that way sites can't come and and
review bombs rock see there you go stuff
like that to the game
it has a level of integrity that's my
thing i don't think these guys want that
right i don't either but king there's
technical issues what if a game crashes
for example pathfinder uh the
pathfinder that came out it had a huge
save game and only some people hit it i
don't know if i would feel comfortable
saying
you can't review this and i don't mean
me as a reviewer i wouldn't review it
i'd be like it's unacceptable i would
just say it's don't buy it but if a
normal person i i like your idea because
by the way open critic already does some
of this right yes that's why i like like
even worded stuff so i get you but i
will also say this i heard one day
people are like all reviewers should
show all your uh trophies so that we can
tell you okay first of all you have all
this stuff but i will tell you this i
shut up a podcast when they were saying
that because i was like not only that
i'll one-up you you all have to take a
[ __ ] quiz excuse my language you have
to take a freaking quiz
and you have to prove you actually know
the game because i've sat through movies
and not remembered a damn thing
so there is a intelligence context
factor right that is not taken into
metacritic right that disturbs me and
that's why when metacritic popped up a
couple days ago and said come check
metacritic and i was like by all means
no one should ever check metacritic
people can spam that
steam reviews are the same revelation
right dude i saw somebody say game was
okay 400 hours in steam what were you
doing for 400 hours in a game that was
okay
no you're absolutely there has to be
context right and that's my thing
because i agree with you guys my thing
is when you hear that you hear the
manipulation and then we hear reports we
had chris grinnell on from sony
liverpool the old wipeout days the old
f1 day you know he talked about in that
building during those times you know
that they looked at that medical critic
store and they looked at that being tied
to bonuses that being tied to success
fallout was tied to bone was it not
fallout new vegas obsidian has
complained and that's what that's what i
struggle with that that's why i i do i
do want to plug one thing because i know
shout out to jaffee i know he had them
on i do want to plug um i can say it
down because public record because colin
just said it but colin is going to have
those guys on he's going to have those
guys on last stand and i do want to see
what they have to say in reference to
that i do want to hear more about the
numbers dude i do want to hear about the
building and i do want to hear about the
pitch because there is a controversy
whether or not because i'm hearing some
people saying well you didn't go to
pitch it so you can't complain if you
didn't pitch it and then i'm here on the
other side where it's like we already
knew we weren't respected in the
building that our head our head guy had
been left because we knew it wasn't is
that what they feel is right they
weren't respected by sony
that that that the writing was
writing was on the wall that they
weren't even respected so much they were
going to be forced to do the the other
thing so why not
basically take my ball and leave because
you don't respect what i'm doing in here
kind of same thing if you're shooting
your shot with a girl you went out on a
date with a chick right and
you knew
the second date was gonna happen so you
just ain't cold right so that's that's
what it is
but you know what i don't know i want to
hear it you got it a good example is
like microsoft uh xbox and their
emphasis stages walking around the
microsoft building you know they're a
laughingstock to everyone and they had a
hard time talking
because that's what i'm saying what if
internally you not yeah like they they
you're not you're not the son that they
know all the other studios are lit and
you re looked at as the kind of the
black sheep that you know you produce so
it is what it is we've gone on let's
just fly through interesting yes five
through the last one thanks i'm sure now
i apologize if i miss your super chat
brother it's been crazy um darnell hill
19 uh it's going to be 20 dollars super
chat it's plague tale is day one and
it's a third person narrative no doubt
splint difference two dollar super chat
eight milli and they still with that
screw face what go on
all right all right you'll see
the attic you gotta help me this thing
moving all over the place on me man
dammit it's off we need you to come back
stop losing my place
what's the last one you're right oh i
think it was a heart
knee this thing jumping and shaking and
uh guys i really want to see this last
one and i'll get more real anyone who's
super chat first of all i owe you guys
an apology you know one of my right
hands is not here so i'm trying my best
but i apologize guys i'm gonna try to
make it up to you guys absolutely none
on my side all right it's cool it's cool
again we will try we will make this
right realm because you guys did super
chat and stuff like that we'll finish
off this last one
this is mine oh shout out hoggy cheney
said here's what i said ubisoft annual
revenue was about 2.5 billion say xbox
is 30 of their revenue and some is in
the form of micro transaction say 600
million in revenue for gains from xbox
at say two dollars g j pass ultimate sub
say 25 million sub that's 600 million it
isn't about 10 dollars to 15 a month
that's what he said one bad mother i
apologize bro yeah it's crazy everyone
tells solve we miss him
because this is what happens when
god got to do everything but we will
make it right we will make it right guys
but last topic um yeah this one is mine
this one came in shout out to um venture
b games beat those guys over there jeff
grubb shout out to dean takahashi and uh
pretty much yeah it says the esa
shifting the e3 expo to on line only
only event during the pandemic it says
due to the ongoing health risks
surrounding covet 19 its potential
impact and the safety of
exhibitors and attendees e3 will not be
held in person in 2022 we remain ex
incredibly excited about the future of
e3 and look forward to announcing more
details soon so it means the show will
take place online for the summer for the
second year in a row and then some more
interesting comments that came out after
this that i want to highlight
shout out to i believe mike fudder
he when that statement was announced by
the esa mike futter said this is spin
like the kids say this is cap i heard
from sources in mid-november from
omicron's um emergence at the end of the
month that the esa had already abandoned
their dates for the los angeles
convention center and then shout out to
jason schreier from bloomberg he also it
already jumped on that he said it sounds
like e3 is all but dead and someone else
come up with an excuse for everyone to
go to la in june and then he also
defended fodder he said by the way 100
100 believe my father's reporting that
the esa gave up on e3 months ago they
would otherwise have been dates on their
website over the pr fluff piece that
they did today no way this is a
knee-jerk reaction to the kova situation
it's e3 throwing in the towel so let's
get it let's start with our acg man what
do you feel about this whole thing e e3
cancellation online only
people you know their reports now saying
that maybe it's fraudulent they were not
you know they were willing to throw it
in already what's your feeling on it so
what people are saying is that they
announced it recently but that the
decision was in november
yeah well when somebody says i've been
talking to somebody i'll just give them
the same scrutiny i get
which is yeah you know right we do and i
think that's fair that's fair um i think
it's also fair that he's probably right
but i would say that most likely they
were also looking at all the things that
are going on because covid can't be
tracked it can't right and even
scientists you talk to be like dude we
thought this was it and it's this we
thought it was going to be worse and
it's this right um i think e3 as a beast
is done
is done and i think online
vr online by the way which i have heard
you know multiple companies are trying
vr uh places where people can go in vr
headsets and talk to developers to see
the games and you know imagine big
screen all of us watching
let's do it so you've got all this right
i'm okay with that i i think e3 was uh
was awesome for its time but you were
always hearing people having difficulty
seeing a game that they wanted to see or
playing it yeah and then they opened it
to the public and then it changed okay
i'm like
things change
and i'm okay with it for now i do think
a personal place you can all go is good
but right now guys it's a petri dish if
you do
i got sick packs prior to kovid and i
mean i never get sick ever i came i was
so ill whatever evil petri dish
emerged into a germ that it devastated
me when i came and it's called pax pox
there's
yeah pax pox is a real thing like people
talk about it so right now it'd be a
pretty bad idea i think to get together
i'm okay with it
uh king we know i gotta go with you
first because uh this is definitely uh a
very sensitive topic i feel for both oh
yeah because you guys go sorry
sorry king we've talked about that yeah
all right i gotta start king first bad
like what what do you think when the
news you saw my
my tweet inside the internal iop chat
when it broke the news so what you found
i was already planning um
uh how we were going to uh attack e3
yeah i was uh already uh in
conversations with uh people
about what was the requirements for
certain individual well certain
companies right uh
for us to attend certain functions
and i'm like i'm i'm on board with that
i'll get a booster too like you know
type of thing um
but at the same time
uh
e3 had their own issues first of all the
security breach actually sunk they ship
be honest
right um and then chasing the bag with
the public
whoever said yes yeah you hated that
yeah
that was your death nail like okay so
and let me explain how you can actually
fix it but you didn't care to fix it
because you would rather sacrifice the
bag than fix your integrity of the venue
situation and you
you felt the money was bigger than the
brand and this is why
if you made that decision in november
then you said we cannot make money in
the status that we did before right so
you looked at the revenue that you made
and you said we can't make this because
we can't track this and we can't make
sure that everybody coming in the venue
is inoculated to the point that we feel
safe
so this is this can't you can't work
okay all right um
if you took it to this
to the genesis of it
you had the developers on site right you
had the media on site yes
that's it
yeah yeah
and you can actually track the media
that's inoculated right that's right
that's true you can track every
developer that's inoculated yeah and you
know who's coming
the scheduling will be a whole lot
cleaner
because we've been to pax
right before the pandemic reached this
apex right and
i'm i've never been in a more sterile
place in my world in my life
the world because they had
you couldn't go up escalated two times
without that whole thing like it was
they would send somebody they would say
wipe it down
oh i wish it had been that way when i
went yeah it was crazy every door knob
every seat every everything was being
wiped down all right so
and i'm and i'm honestly telling you i
felt safe as hell like i was in there i
was like wow this it smelled great it
packs east yeah
you know how you usually smell like
sweaty elbows
yeah those are the body what it was
king was looking at these people was
like where do i hire you
it was it was great stuff but yeah they
valued the money over the the the brand
they already felt the pushback
and
let's just keep it real
ryan is killing him
oh you mean jeff i mean jeff yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah jeffy's kid yeah
the the sony departure coupled
sony departures from exit from e3
coupled with jeff's own summer game fest
show he's killing them and the
and the companies on show yeah and the
pandemic and a failed online event
and he's successful he's successfully
doing
the summer games thing virtually
right right so then you eliminate what's
going on for e3 because microsoft did
they own during e3 time
did they own e3 right which was virtual
the the adaption rate was so quick
they weren't able to recover
and they weren't willing to take the
steps to recover right so
we lose the venue
and you guys both know the developers
themselves have talked about how
expensive it is
um what's his name cliff bazinski in the
fighting the 800-pound gorilla video he
did he was like dude it's like insanely
expensive to make a vertical chop where
if it's recorded we can make sure now
there's some other things there but it
it i mean there's a lot of cost and for
us
dude it sunk me uh financially oh facts
oh no it's real it's real
we had a we had to put a pot away for
you okay did you ruin the food like you
get in and you're like you know the food
was expensive the hotels are my god we
got this little podunk hotel and it was
more than my mortgage and i was just
like airbnb yeah we had the airbnb this
year and we have we have a system i have
a system king had it rocking that
actually works um
it was comfortable
the way we work the way we get cars
um for the rental system
we got into an affordable
actual uh below if i tell you acg that
you went there for a thousand dollars
for the week and that's with travel food
and all expenses paid and we had to be
like yeah that's that's impossible but
that's how we got it down to uh because
you look at the science and you break it
down and you share you have to lean on
each other to actually make it happen of
course right and we stay in very
comfortable yeah everybody got their own
room six to eight a lot of your favorite
content creators like swimming pools yes
it was a huge house it was crazy it was
i missed those days i missed that yeah
but it's it's gone yeah no attic i don't
know if you're still there you muted
doing what you're doing but
i'm here okay yeah i mean what do you
feel man i know this was
something we talked about during the
pandemic about kind of being excited to
go back out but here we are again
and what do you feel about this e3 thing
man it really feels like the people who
run e3
the moment they had competition yeah
wrap it up it's over like
wrap it up b box
because it's like
they could easily bring e3 back because
what they're having they're just not
having to worry about the money now
they're having to worry about oh man
jeff got got got that reveal oh man like
now they're having to worry about news
going somewhere else yeah
and i feel like people respect jeff more
they respect whoever's running that
stuff right yeah so it's i think it's a
combination of everything i i do feel
like something's going to replace e3
yeah i mean it's this where where it's
going
yeah what'd you say
we back out there baby
there's there's other ones yeah the
camera for sure but i think asg made
some fantastic points so jump in and
sense that like look
that year away
developers
companies publishers realize how much
money we can really save if we just do
it our own
we don't really need to invest we've
already talked about again the vertical
slice how stressful how hard that is to
create these things for specific events
that actually takes away from the
development cycle sometimes yeah because
they this was the thing now i will say
you know i do miss decentralization of
everybody in one spot i do miss that i i
i yeah the camaraderie of course the
memories we have there and look we got
to be a haunted official like iop
probably wouldn't be where it's at
without our presence going to e3 without
being there
on that line you know taking every hand
kissing every baby so i i do owe a lot
we owe a lot to ourselves i mean king we
started the more i mean you started the
movement every person you gave out an
ilp show no one knew who we were
you know what i'm saying people would
come up to us like yo you guys are
esports team remember that they were
like what everybody we all have our
unified joy they got lord on the back
and just the memories man i'm gonna miss
it uh you know i'm gonna miss the
memories i'm gonna miss you know going
uh one thing about this
it was fun but man it was work oh it was
worse oh yeah
oh
you lift it doesn't matter you go home
you're still tired
you're tired you're exhausted your feet
hurt you better have comfortable shoes
because you better go from the east hall
to the west hall you want to you'll be
soft you're going to be this confident
you're going to be able to face yourself
pace yourself but the moment you know we
missed you know shot the king the
potential movement you know what i'm
saying there we got the the skyrim you
know
brontosaurus legs
i accidentally took uh data i wasn't
supposed to take from ubisoft
and vermintide guys are my friends to
this day that was the first time i saw
them but yeah i took i took a bunch of
uh data on accident i took the wrong usb
[Applause]
so listen so josh and i are there we're
running around and by the way one of the
best pr guys ever he doesn't work for
ubisoft anymore just absolutely
incredible he walked me through
everything bob was helping us and he
gave me a pd he gave me a usb with the
wrong data we and all of a sudden about
an hour later shot it's like three in
the morning josh's cell phone's just
pinging and it's like
and josh he's like wakes up he comes
over he's like dude he's saying you have
like proprietary ubisoft information
so we had to meet him and hand it over
he's like i just want to thank you you
didn't copy it i'm like no of course not
don't don't don't lie
right before you
don't lie like right before right before
you was okay where are you going
that's how you guys we're gonna be there
like 30 minutes again
it's the travel it's good
it's gonna take me a little while what
no no no no
i wanted to but no he was so cool and
and those kind of you're right you're
right those kind of i had somebody stop
it was that when i'm sure twenty five
thousand dollars yeah they someone
stopped at 25 000 it walked up to you
and walk up to you and it's just like
whoa this is amazing amazing brother i i
wasn't thinking about that because those
memories are a while ago but yeah most
of my friends also yeah are from
um from those events yeah within gaming
i just want to shout out a couple of
people again you know king would know
again fan fest we have to shout out you
know the tremendous camaraderies the
people we met there then going to
actually our the microsoft press
conference being in there that's cool
you know what i'm saying i remember
hopefully you guys get to meet phil of
course regularly king is always in the
vip i was i had to maneuver for kings
already
you know what i said but i was able to
hold out the monkey bar at times check
it out
you're wearing your jacket wearing your
fur yeah i'm a huge knight
this is funny right because this year
cog is the only one that got media
so cog is going in media he has the big
stuff that he's going through
he comes into the media room and he sees
me and monkey eating in the back i was
like what is this it's so hot
that's amazing i showed him my media
badge
[Laughter]
bro it's just the moments that obviously
you know king and everybody being failed
shout out to bill stilwell shout out to
hearing the backward compatibility
announcement for the first time
um
so many things xcloud the things like
that i remember shout out to shout out
to kanye west for taking my hololens
appointment
because they bumped me for kanye west
and i'm still in my feelings about it i
thought i should still be on the level i
was invited to hollow lens davey before
anyone saw it acg so i was all hyped and
he took it and they had to give me
another five slot microsoft oh baby
um yeah kanye came through so um the
slot's gone i am so i was like damn it
but you gotta understand it respect
for sure king remember shout out to
ubisoft with oh you were mad when they
had just pizza at the event they had
them um when you started getting bougie
with the after parties and you start oh
yeah
okay so we get really good food
then we get over there they just had
pizza and red bulls
[Music]
wait did you just say ubisoft yeah yeah
it was the first time what happened to
me with watch dogs they have these
little tiny like weird pizza things yeah
no well i was at watch dogs
no we was that we was that ferocious i
don't remember we did the watchtower
thing in the back you may be right
remember they had the whole sense of the
pcs yeah yeah
did they have a lady talk about
cybertech
right we're with this same time
that is so crazy yeah so i went there
and they had this little food and i
remember josh and i big guys meat eaters
and i'm sitting there looking at this
little [ __ ] thing and i don't do
carbs and so i'm sitting there and i'm
like
you know scrape a little meat off and
i'm like oh no dude where and of course
ubisoft there this group i think a lot
of them were not from america there were
some people there that were speaking
french and stuff and they're all thin
and [ __ ] i just show up and i'm like
where's the beef
that's not the bad and it was all red
bulls it was all energy drinks
it took a bunch of
so many members last couple was nintendo
but what's up king they always had us
with the red uh mario odyssey hats
you know what shout out to shout out to
attic always finding a way
to find the
anime i want to say boothbay
or anything
very very um
very good
voluptuous people i got to give them
addict found a way to get those
interviews for us
awesome i gotta give a shout out to todd
mcfarlane yes oh shout out to tommy yes
for remembering me so he's on the line
to go to battlefield right yes
and he remembers me from comic book days
mm-hmm
and he sees me he goes out
come here
come here that's cool that was cool and
he's like cut the line look at the hell
yeah
dude really yeah that's awesome man that
was that's so great i'm doing this and
he had a toy with him that he uh the
prototype of it and we're talking about
the prototype and he had a private
session
for for a battlefield yeah and they was
like all right todd your session is it
he's like come on let's go yeah let's go
oh dude man
everybody i will admit i'm sure you guys
agree everybody dude all the developers
i met and sometimes i didn't like a game
or two they were all so awesome i think
twitter is actually worse because
sometimes a developer may not be mad at
you but what they tweet may sound weird
i got to sit down with them and they
weren't i know when somebody's pr nice
yeah they were certainly those people
and that's fine too but man like the
vermintide guys we laughed i mean even
when we left they're like i've never
done an interview with a youtuber that's
like this because we just teased each
other
in terrible vermintide gameplay and they
by the time they were done they were
like this was the greatest interview
i've known him for years he's been on
the podcast and those kind of those
relationships kind of things where yeah
where he's just like hey come over and
look at my new toy that no one else like
people don't people treat them like not
the the product is a product but the
people
you know human they're human yeah and a
lot of times they may be a fan i found
that out recently when i said something
bad about a game so it does you know you
like remember that there's a person on
the other person on the other side and
that was the thing it was the
camaraderie to meet people that was
awesome final shout out
rooftop party
e3 rooftop shout out to megatron shots
you ran that part knowing how to keep me
shut yeah get you with the fight yeah
yeah
you know
yo ac right so i i watch the fights and
i'm not into i'm not a huge party dude
i'm not into all that stuff right right
so i watch the fights
he knows to ply me with liquor and sit
me down in front of a boxing match and
i'm quiet it was like kicking the fights
right here if you want to see he found
some random dude
watching the fight on his phone yeah oh
so you could
i don't notice dude
sometimes you got to go to the rooftop
joints to schmooze you know yeah
i love that stuff and and it was just
what i know king was going to be a
scratch because i know he's boxing that
night
king's boxing i'm not showing up he's
like i'm gonna watch the fight he's like
i'm gonna watch the fight and i'm like i
gotta try to figure a way to keep him
here
so you found a random person watching it
all right
i'm like bro yo king the fight
you can come up
you're taking care of you exactly he
kept a drinker pop up i'm like yeah and
that then i'd buy a chicken like here
you go bro
that's awesome at the last point i got a
shout out attic man like we we had some
fun moments you know one of our
favorites was actually adding whatever
we did you be something yeah they had to
ask
the question
that was like the big like it's you can
you can find this on youtube yes it's on
youtube okay
i asked him a question and they
they i've never seen this much like
circling around a question in my life
like it was like a live question and
then they instead of like answering or
giving me pro they clowned my question
yeah like also was this ubisoft too yeah
ubisoft also showed me the wrong game
uh ahead of time and at the other packs
and had it
what is going on mine was assassin's
creed syndicate i got to see it way
before i was supposed to and they were
like
they're like whoa wait
that was not the game because i don't
know if you guys remember but rogue and
syndicate were like you know there's and
you don't and there's some overlap don't
like it don't lie acg that was on that
that was
remember adding we walk in the streets
after going from cops to conference and
we run it
shout out to michael factor he had that
whiskey in the head he's a little late
before you know like the entire destiny
yesterday it was just it was you just
get these random moments
of everyone in the same pocket and it's
like here's michael pachter here and
this person right here you know there's
ryan mccaffrey there there's the
developer of your favorite game there he
is phil spencer but like everyone in the
same pocket with an ear shot and it was
just these amazing conversations and
dynamics that you would never had as a
gamer it was like geek fraternity it was
just like yelled at phil spencer in the
street oh my god what'd you do what'd
you get it he walked by and i i fanned
out i guess i don't know man i feel like
i don't i wasn't in control of my body
i'm not lying
this is it it was seen by multiple
thousands of people it was a busy street
with tons of people and i saw him and
i'm like
phil spencer you've been rob
and i'm not lying i'm pretty loud
obviously like i think i stopped half of
the town and they all just looked at me
and phil goes thanks and walked off and
i was like whoa that was a good response
that was good and i don't know if he
remembers but it was one of the most i
mean and even i remember the person with
me josh he looked at me and he's like
what happened yeah
yeah let's just go dude let's get out of
here that's a good moment good moment
it's funny and shout out to reggie
phillips and may team for pulling the
guns out for me getting a little too
close to reggie in the control level
that was funny
reggie rolls to security i thought i was
gonna fanboy out and say hey reg what's
up bro
did you get the bodyguard yeah the body
but yeah the 6'4 dude came through and i
was like oh
wherever he sees me shout out to the
ferragamos though he yell
so we're talking in the
larry is the realest person i know he's
and he gets a lot of crap he's at two
o'clock in the morning yeah he's pretty
sharp in the fire pit
with all the fan fest people that want
to get into fan fest factual chopping it
up factual no security no nobody larry
being larry
so larry sees me have a hell of a
conversation there
seeing larry like three four times after
that every time larry sees me he yells
at yo bro bro
that's awesome man no that's i love that
fun memories yeah go miss it gonna miss
it don't look good but we'll see what
happens
i do feel like
something's going to take that probably
could replace it
all right
i just don't know if it will be open to
the public got a few super chats that i
did find that i missed uh butterball two
dollar super chat um gonna name my next
tcl tv after king salute no he said that
okay he said that did we get victor
allison happy new year's lord did we get
um okay we got that we got oh one bad
mother 10 hour super chat happy new year
my friend great to see you much deserve
success in 2021 2022 will be bigger
happy to see iop star show start time
accommodates my late saturday night halo
marathon gaming schedule no does salute
tony bryant the division for honor and
siege ac odyssey and origins all in game
pass ubisoft already in the back seat
necking with gig i heard necking in a
while no no
you just defined his example
no doubt connecting the doctor 63 5
super chat made it in time for the
ubisoft topic glad the lords are back
salute we got the don o taco i got you
already we got both down on tacos jim
okay i got you i think i'm caught up
there we got yep i think okay pragmatic
eagle can't agree more with what acg
said about metacritic that effectively
sums up why i don't place any credence
on rev review scores zero context no del
fazzo rally gaming salute eight months
you know salute to him muscle up to my
brothers here at the iop he should be up
soon with our game talk live so add it
catch it if i missed anything else
because did you get the uh the one from
trikey about ubisoft annual revenues no
two points oh yeah i did that i got that
one i got that one making sure i think
brothers again i apologize if i missed
anything i've been tracking a little bit
and i actually think you guys have got
them all because you repeated one or two
okay actually this one makes sure
because got four dollars worth of
discord
okay
new ilp lognet poll this week with the
recent success of the meta quest 2 and
the anticipation of playstation vr2 how
should xbox approach their potential
future involvement in the vr space the
choices are eight develop their own vr
headset in the gaming space to compete
b partner with an established vr
platform holder to integrate xbox and
gameplatform
c don't enter the vr space and focus
strictly on console gaming king shakes
his head or d i don't care i'm all in
owning all your nfts in the metaverse
salute everybody
that rocks the vote for will be going up
again salute the lord boom who came
through double barrel gaming my man
boosting excel
and of course the legendary acg
rocking with us the entire way brother i
appreciate you so much always good
always a blast you already know where
can i find people find you what you got
going on sir
um angry centaur gaming is actually now
that i think about the url on the
youtube channel but acg is what i'm
known for yes some reviews coming up in
the next couple days uh very very soon
i'll just say and then
we are ex dude i don't know what's going
on but we're exploding on our patreon
which is really nice because my reviews
are just all over the place right now
with numbers so you can check me out um
acg patron if you want to check out
there if you don't it's totally fine
and uh you will see i got a website up
you'll see some stuff there slowly with
news and blogs and stuff nothing like
you guys are doing just me you know by
myself just sort of like here's my
here's my bad idea let me let me throw
it let me infect your brain with my
cancer it's a bad idea
and uh yeah man you'll just see me
reviewing games it's gonna be an awesome
year i'm excited for it and i'm excited
for gaming man i really am like this
year last year was
incredible
and this year
i hope to see the same no doubt no doubt
man salute to you brother absolute
pleasure i always have you in there to
send acg his flowers bruh
yeah i definitely appreciate coming off
man there is not a lot of people you
meet that you that you know is 100
genuine because like there'll be people
i know for years i'm like is it this
year he gonna stab me in the back
oh
[Applause]
the people at this podcast acg fawns
like
their genuine as as much as genuine
could possibly be yes sir uh you know
definitely go check me out in here if
you guys weren't i appreciate you guys
definitely
go check out acg's reviews man like
some of
sometimes i i i've been trying to like
dip my toes in the review pool a little
bit and like and then i'll get like the
feedback all you know uw and i'm just
thinking you double repeat stuff but i
was just like oh my god like it is not
as easy as like some people on the in
this chat be like
man all you're doing is talking to a
camera at night
talk to him oh thank you
there's the difference between playing a
game
and
knowing how knowing how to break down
again yeah facts and i don't think
people realize that that line is a lot
bigger than people right and don't
appreciate the the technical mastery
that acg does with a lot of things
reviewers leave out in games music sound
you know a lot of these other
intricacies that we gotta keep pushing
it so we can get more musical artists
yeah on these channels too right that's
gonna
we need to composers yes
we actually that's how we i wanted to to
lean a little bit on the like the voice
actors and composers
but like i wouldn't even know where to
start with that stuff like i can get you
started if you guys want some people
that i've had oh yeah yeah absolutely
yeah i can give you something
that would love
graphics gets to shine but
it's not like you playing in the void
right yeah and then oh dude yeah okay
so here's the thing that's going on um
tomorrow i will be releasing my thoughts
on this whole xbox and square enix thing
that'll be on my channel
uh tuesday
my oculus review will come out so uh
uh that definitely uh first off myself
let's go yeah from there and i'm gonna
probably name it vr you gotta name it
so i'll probably david that
uh and you know i'm to start streaming
more on twitch because i actually enjoy
streaming on twitch i don't know you got
a word
shirt
a revealing shirt okay is that was that
better oh god
actually i'm in here
i'm a millionaire
so so definitely if you guys have
babylon
if you guys haven't followed the twitch
channel definitely go there and uh
follow it you know i'm gonna i'm just
i'm gonna be streaming horizon zero dawn
because that game the sequel's about to
come out and i've never played the
original one oh good whoa
you know you'll fall asleep just like me
so i will play that and then you know i
i
then i'll probably i think i'm going to
probably play destiny for a couple weeks
because i really got it yeah we got to
get catch up and back for blood yes yeah
back for blood we got to jump in again
actually
my most memorable moment of back for
blood is
what one time literally i was the only
one alive and i'm running through the
subway or this suit no i think it was it
was it was a tunnel of some sort it and
i've tried like you know the little
the monkeys that you throw in in call of
duty that like yeah
they got one of those on there too so so
like what's one of these acts like just
keep going don't worry about us and i
was like no and i threw the little
monkey
and it was way over their head but hey
you know what he attempted
he lived he attempted and by the way
please before i know we need to wrap up
but i do need your guys's vr names so
yes brother i saw your tweets i just
didn't track what my name even was
inside of there
yeah after this joint go oh i'm king
let's give acg flowers man well
first of all um give a shout out to my
brother boom who was here oh yes with
the ball
you did this thing and and comes with
that insight i love your stuff and now
probably the hardest working oh for sure
he has like every time i tune in there's
like 20 different shows yeah we've got
that show going absolutely what i like
about acg you know and
and i i love what he comes on
but what i like about his reviews
because his reviews will pop up and it's
even buy it or don't you know type of
thing not uh
uh anything else with it it's you know
buy it on his suggestions to it um
his personality
comes through is
that the guy that you get what you see
is what you get
in in in the video so it's not like you
get a video you know now you see dudes
right they on the show totally different
then you see their reviews well right
here see
why you gotta do it right right
so i i really love his personality and i
think that's why you're so successful
yes thank you because you didn't you you
don't fraud
uh you didn't change your voice
oh this is the radio voice oh no
you're just you
and i thank you i really appreciate that
and it's little things and and like alex
said you know adam said uh who's gonna
stab me in the back no
i don't do that but
i notice
when you don't think acg is watching
he's paying attention yeah you pay
something
random
and he'll retweet like yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
making enemies every moment on twitter
and i gotta i gotta follow the thread oh
that's how i was linked in that yeah i
do need a statue of myself yeah yeah
that is true i forgot that one that is
true
all right for you guys let's get it this
is i want y'all to clip it joe y'all can
talk about me in spaces
all right guys
so
combat talk with the kid is covered
we're getting the music together the
music is set um king of the statues the
music is set new intros artists
everything is gonna go up and i have a
whole vision for this year for what iop
is gonna be
and if right now you look and you're
saying he looks like a mix with 50 cent
rick they sure get sure too chanced out
won't stop take that take that take that
it's coming you can't stop it pause no
doubt salute man again tremendous show
shout out shout out to acg shout out to
the chat
good to be back again we can read the
final one shout out to matt titchborn
that is the man without fear i think i
remember you you added me on oculus on
welcome welcome to enjoy it yeah i teach
bond oh yeah
so uh welcome to lord silva crazy horse
two dollars super chat do you think
don't drink that don't drink that's
cheap
but do you think geforce now is coming
to xbox i don't know
no
i always thought it would go to uh
nintendo because it's native to the
system no doubt shout out
no gtl or green because rand has uh had
to cancel he said yeah yeah everyone
says he loved iran he's going through
some vertical man please send some love
to brand outdoor man with the million
shout out to stitch remember 26.
everyone stay safe i'm recovering from
covid oh man hope to be back to 100
before my wife goes into labor next week
switching to you had to still throw
switch in the bushes even though you
sick and you can't really check you are
savage thank you you had it don't switch
letters he wouldn't be stitch if he has
a switch later and i think we are all
caught up but everybody again angry
centaur gaming on youtube check out my
brother double barrel gaming on youtube
subscribe to the channel support the
content honest good content creators
good stuff good to be back and you
didn't let me say anything nice and i
didn't let you say anything nice so
you're now not nice
no i i do want to say just real quick um
i don't i am super i'm busier than
normal with behind the scenes stuff and
i don't come on a lot of podcasts
anymore it's just it is like a big block
of time as you guys can tell yes and um
are
i can definitely tell that our
communities overlap like even seeing
super chats and mine in yours i'm like
oh wait you know we we like overlap here
and it's i do believe that especially
now when you look at the way you guys
cover games the way i cover games there
is luckily a little bit more desire to
have fun yes a little bit more desire to
also be um solid no matter what and be
like well and i've dealt with uh cognito
on the side on all kinds of stuff and
it's a very it is rare yeah that i mean
it is rare i've been on a couple and
it's like oh that was fun but i don't
desire it right where like you dm'd me
and i was like
all right my god i got to figure out
time appreciation
and that's why like in reviews i've
dropped you guys uh writing on games is
another amazing youtuber and like being
on here and talking to you guys is
awesome it is very it is very different
here than most other places i'll just
say that it's there's something about it
that is is very cool and it gets me
excited
no matter what like three hours in i'm
still like
are we over
we can talk for another so i just want
to say man
like it it's it's phenomenal seeing you
guys and hopefully you guys continue to
get the growth i've noticed the numbers
were super high
um for watches i hope that continues and
stuff like i wish you guys all the best
in 2022 appreciate it brother again 2023
yeah 2020
i'm doing track two now brother i
appreciate you man it means a lot and um
you know one thing about us like king
said you know as far as being genuine
and you know just being who you are
you've always been that person and
that's what's so cool the chemistry is
obviously communities overlap and then i
always like topics like this because i'm
like oh damn my momma go acg me perfect
for this show i was like yo
we could tell i can have something
inside
it just and then i could vibe and it
becomes this fun thing and that's what i
like but look everybody enjoy your
sunday the lords are back we'll be back
next week saying bad time bad channel 1
p.m eastern hit yeah yes 11 p.m you feel
good with this 1pm right man yeah i woke
up completely energized man i feel like
i need to get to some one of those
things the energizer bunny uses you just
start clapping it i'm done i'm done
going back to 11 a.m
everybody you'll just see me drop them
in the middle of it
anyway everybody enjoy your sunday we
out peace
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign